I'm not the Messiah! I'm not the Messiah, will you please listen?
I am not the Messiah, do you understand?
He is!
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 64 und das Thema des heutigen Tages, ja, erstmal vorstellen, nicht vergessen, hier am Mikrofon Tim Pritlove und ja, das Thema heute bei diesem Podcast dreht sich rund um die Bedienbarkeit von Dingen. Im Fokus stehen Usability, Interaktionsdesign und generell das Verhältnis zwischen dem Menschen und der Maschine. Und dazu habe ich zwei Gäste eingeladen. Mit der Dame fangen wir an. Ellen, hallo Ellen. Ellen Reitmayr, du bist schon lange auf Usability-Pfaden unterwegs und hast dort schon so einiges geleistet. Da werden wir auch jetzt in weiteren der Sendung eingehen. Und zu rechten der Peter Sikking, hallo. Auch du bewegst dich in einem ähnlichen Feld, aber wir haben eben schon im Vorgespräch festgestellt, es gibt einen kleinen Unterschied zwischen euren Methoden. Auch das werden wir versuchen herauszuarbeiten. Ja, hallo, willkommen bei Chaosradio Express. Usability, ist das eigentlich ein neues Wort? Seit wann gibt es denn das eigentlich?
Tja, seit wann es das Wort gibt, weiß ich nicht so genau. Das weiß ich, ja.
Hat irgendwann mal jemand erfunden.
Wir sind mit den 90 Jahren mainstream gekommen, mindestens in Europa, dass ich mehr und mehr um mich herumgehört habe. Aber wir sind sicher in der Research und sicher in der Mirka schon mal zehn Jahre vorher wirklich als...
Heute habe ich in einem Beitrag gelesen, das schon seit 65 Jahren, glaube ich, die Studien zum Thema Usability gibt. Damals natürlich noch nicht mit Webseiten. Aber eben mit Geräten und im Einsatz in der Produktion.
Das Erfinder von der Maus ist Mitte 60 Jahren. Dreiknopfmaus und irgendwelche runden kleine Displays.
Man mag es nicht glauben. Was steckt denn drin in dem Begriff? Also Usability, frei übersetzt, ist die Benutzbarkeit von Dingen. Aber was versucht man denn heute damit wirklich zu umreißen? Also was deckt dieser Begriff tatsächlich ab?
Also die korrekte Übersetzung ist Gebrauchstauglichkeit. Da gibt es auch eine DIN-Norm, die diese Gebrauchstauglichkeit definiert. Und zwar als das Ausmaß, indem ein Produkt in einem bestimmten Aufgabenkontext durch einen bestimmten Benutzer zufriedenstellend, effektiv und effizient gebraucht werden kann. Ziemlich komplex. Ich muss auch ein bisschen nachdenken, um es richtig hinzukriegen. Aber trotzdem, die DIN-Norm trifft das eigentlich. Hast du die Nummer parat? DIN 9241 110. Ne 111. Also ich hoffe, dass es stimmt. 9241 100 vorne stimmt auf jeden Fall. Es sind entweder die 10 oder die 11. Die DIN-Norm hört sich zwar etwas kompliziert an, trifft aber den Kern. Also es geht eben um bestimmte Nutzergruppen, für die im Rahmen einer bestimmten Aufgabenstellung das Produkt, die Software oder die Webseite oder was auch immer eben besonders gut nutzbar sein soll, ohne Barrieren zu bedienen sein soll.
Das heißt, es hängt immer vom Kontext ab.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Und die Usability, mit der du dich jetzt auseinandergesetzt hast bisher, ist aber im Wesentlichen die Usability, die Anwendung von Software, richtig?
Software und Webseiten, genau. Teilweise auch kleine Geräte, also Handys oder irgendwelche Navigationsgeräte, solche Dinge, aber vor allem eben elektronische Technik.
Und wie bist du dazu gekommen, das zu tun?
Na ja, ich bin Psychologin, das ist auch der kleine Unterschied zwischen Peter und mir. Also ich arbeite eben empirisch, was die Usability auch ausmacht. Man geht zu den Nutzern, erhebt Daten und wertet diese Daten dann aus und daraus bekommt man eben Erkenntnisse, wie eine Webseite entweder komplett gestaltet werden soll, eben um ein Konzept zu machen als Input für eine Anforderungsanalyse, für Anforderungen. Oder man verbessert eben ein bestehendes Produkt durch diese Daten, die man sammelt. Und als Psychologin lernt man eben genau das ins Feld zu gehen und Studien zu betreiben.
Also empirisch heißt, auf Erfahrung aufbauen, wie weit muss man dann zurückblicken, blättert man dann so die letzten 100 Jahre der Gerätebenutzung nach?
Oder ist es auf Wahrnehmung aufbauen?
Ja, auf Wahrnehmung zum einen. Also spielen verschiedene Dinge zusammen. Zum einen eben ja Wahrnehmungspsychologie, zum anderen kognitive Psychologie. Und dann eben auch tatsächlich Studien durchzuführen und zu gucken, wie verhalten sich denn die Nutzer jetzt vorm Rechner? Wenn sie diese und diese Aufgabe durchführen müssen, wie gehen sie dabei vor? Und wie können wir ihnen optimal unterstützen, diese Aufgabe zu erfüllen?
Das heißt, du bist dann eigentlich, hast du dann auch ein abgebrochenes Studium vorzuweisen? Nein, ich bin Diplompsychologin, tatsächlich.
Aber mit Nebenfachinformatik muss ich ja immer zu meiner Rettung dazu sagen.
Okay, aber gut, da zeigt sich natürlich dann auch schon die Veranlagung sozusagen. Und ja, wie hast du das dann konkret umgesetzt für dich? Also was waren dann so die ersten Schritte?
Ähm, in der Ausbildung jetzt? Oder habe ich dazu gekommen?
Ja, wie du einfach dann so Usability als dein Feld gefunden hast. Weil das ist ja nun nicht gerade eine populäre Tätigkeit, wo man viele Role-Models auf der Straße rumgehen sieht und sich denkt, so cool will ich auch mal sein.
Naja, das war schon im Studium. Ich sollte für meinen Wahrnehmungspsychologen eben auch ein bisschen programmieren. Da haben wir so ein Baukastensystem zum einfachen Zusammenklicken psychologischer Experimente erstellt. Und da gab es eben immer wieder Probleme, wie wir das Interface gestalten sollen. Und da dachte ich mir, das ist ja eigentlich auch ganz interessant. Was gibt es denn da für Berufsfelder? Und so bin ich da dann reingeschlittert.
Das war jetzt eine Webseite oder das war ein Programm?
Nein, das war ein Programm, ein Java-Programm. Hab ich so im Kleinen auch mitprogrammiert. Und da kamen eben immer wieder diese Interface-Probleme. Machen wir das jetzt besser so oder so? Und niemand wusste genau und wusste nicht, wie man es eben rauskriegen soll, wie man es jetzt am besten umsetzt. Und dann bin ich da so in das Thema Usability reingeschlittert.
Dein Beitrag in dem Moment war konkret, einfach dir darüber Gedanken zu machen, wie spricht jetzt das Programm tatsächlich mit dem Anwender?
Genau, und was will der Anwender da genau eigentlich tun und wie soll das Programm aussehen, um ihn zu unterstützen?
Und worüber macht man sich da als erstes Gedanken?
Na, man muss erstmal rauskriegen, wer sind die Anwender? Das ist ja Peters Spezialgebiet auch. Er ist immer, klopft zuerst mal.
In zwei Sätzen zusammen, wer es genau benutzen soll und der Rest ist uns sehr krass gesagt, muss dann, wenn es wirklich um Entscheidungen ankommt, danach auch egal sein. Also, dass man sehr fokussiert auf einen Haufen von Leuten. Ja, die sind alle anders, aber ja, bei allen Gemeinsamkeiten. Und daneben gibt es dann ganze Gruppen von Benutzer. Da kann es tauchlich sein, aber manchmal kann man auch Pech haben. Aber man muss sich konzentrieren auf das Wesentliche.
Ja, dann stellt man eben die Anforderungen, die diese Nutzergruppe an die Software oder die Webseite hat, auf und überprüft die Software oder Webseite anhand dieser Anforderungen.
Vielleicht mal so konkret an diesem Beispiel, was du genannt hast, also bei diesem Programm. Was war dann sozusagen dein Beitrag dort konkret? Hast du dann erstmal so einen Workflow aufgezeichnet, hast ja so ein DIN-A0-Blatt aus deinem Drucker gezogen und dann erst mal angefangen mit Wachsmalstiften Schema aufzubauen?
Also damals war ja mein Hauptding Programmieren. Und ich war da noch extrem unerfahren. Und deswegen war das sicher nicht die beste Methode. Also was wir damals gemacht haben war, dass wir erstmal geguckt haben, was muss es eigentlich alles geben und uns die Informationsarchitektur dann überlegt haben. Also welche Informationen oder welche Dinge, Funktionen wird man mit diesem Programm ausführen? Und wie passen die am besten zusammen? Also zum Beispiel die Menüstruktur. Wenn der Nutzer eben eine bestimmte Aufgabe erledigt, wie denkt er, dass diese Punkte zusammengehören, sodass man eben das Menü in einer sinnvollen Art und Weise aufbaut? Das war so der erste Punkt.
Im Allgemeinen ist es wesentlich, ein richtiges Gefühl zu bekommen, wie die Leute eigentlich ticken und wie sie ihren eigenen Job sehen, ihre eigenen Aufgaben sehen und wie man Sachen auf dem Bildschirm und in Interaktionen, also wie das fließt, strukturieren kann, damit sie da am effizientsten durchkommen. Also es hängt total von dieser Berufsgruppe oder diesen User-Gruppen ab.
Was ist jetzt der empirische Aspekt, weil du das ja vorhin erwähnt hast?
Na, der empirische Aspekt ist eben tatsächlich, möglichst immer Daten zu sammeln. Natürlich entwickelt man halt über die Jahre auch Erfahrungen und bestimmte Heuristiken. Also man weiß dann einfach, wenn man auf einer Webseite guckt, auf den ersten Blick, okay, das wird sicher nicht funktionieren. Andere Dinge, da denkt man, das wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren. Und wieder andere Dinge kriegt man eben auch wirklich nur raus, wenn man da Nutzer vorne dransetzt und denen eben Aufgaben gibt und denen über die Schulter guckt und schaut, wo Probleme sind. Manchmal sind das wirklich ganz unerwartete Dinge. Und deswegen ist eben tatsächlich Datenerheben mit Nutzern immer das Beste. Wo es auch sehr wichtig ist, Daten zu erheben, ist in der Anforderungsanalyse. Weil man kann sich natürlich viele Gedanken machen, was die Nutzer brauchen werden. Aber man kriegt das nur wirklich raus, wenn man ins Feld geht und denen mal ein E-Mail-Client in einer bestimmten Firma, denen über die Schulter guckt und so schaut, wie arbeiten die Leute dort eigentlich mit E-Mail, was wird damit alles erledigt, welche Abläufe gibt es dort, wie wird das mit der Umgebung, mit anderen Dateien integriert. Und das muss dann eben einfach auch oben werden im Feld.
Es ist einfach andocken an der Realität, statt sich am eigenen Büro zu denken von Gott.
Der Feind jedes Programmierers. Um noch mal kurz zu deinem Werdegang zurückzugehen, du hast ja deine ersten Bewährungsproben gemacht und dann hast du ein bisschen Blut geleckt und dir gedacht, na fein, das wäre jetzt auch mal wirklich ein Punkt, wo ich jetzt meine psychologischen Grundkenntnisse anbringen kann und trotzdem Spaß mit Computern haben kann.
Genau, richtig.
Und wie hast du dich dann da professionalisiert?
Ja, das war gar nicht so einfach in Deutschland zu der Zeit. Also es ist jetzt nicht so lange her, sechs Jahre, sieben Jahre. Also vor fünf Jahren war ich mit dem Studium fertig. Seitdem hat sich viel getan, aber es gab damals einfach nicht viele Universitäten, wo man Usability jetzt als Studienfach oder als Kurs angeboten bekommen hat. Wenn, dann war das stark an die Informatik angelehnt, wo es eben nicht so um diese psychologischen Methoden geht, sondern mehr wirklich um Anwendung von Heuristiken, wo man eben solche Dinge lernt. Und was ich dann gemacht hab, war eben, mich durch Praktika weiterzubilden. Bei der IBM in Böbling, da gibt es ein großes Usability-Lab, und da war ich dann halt insgesamt ein Jahr, mich dort weitergebildet und eben durch, naja, Literatur, was man eben so machen kann. Nach dem Studium bin ich dann eben ziemlich schnell nach Berlin gekommen und dort auch in das Projekt Open Usability, das wir gegründet haben. Da geht es darum, Usability in Open Source-Projekte zu bringen und das eben auch eine sehr gute Möglichkeit, sich weiterzubilden, gerade eben für Berufsanfänger, weil man in den Open Source-Projekten eben, da sind ja auch viele Studenten, die programmieren, und genauso wird es halt auch als Usability-Mensch dann verziehen, wenn man mal am Anfang noch nicht so ganz treffsicher ist oder...
Zum Sandkasten.
Ja, genau, und einfach auch lernen, Studien durchzuführen, solche Dinge. Das hat dann sehr gut geklappt in Open Usability.
Open Usability habt ihr gegründet, wann?
2003 gab es die Idee und 2004 im Frühjahr war dann die Plattform online.
Ihr beide habt das gemacht oder waren da noch mehr Leute mit dabei?
Nee, das war der Jan Mülik vor allem und die Jutta Horstmann. Die hatten... Ja, das war im Rahmen einer Wette. Die Jutta hat gesagt, dass Linux, also sie ist eine Informatikerin, und hat gesagt, Linux wäre doch genauso benutzungsfreundlich wie Windows. Und der Jan als Mac-User hat gesagt, nein, das kann gar nicht sein. Und dann haben sie eine Wette abgeschlossen.
Und Mac-User hat er sich zu Windows geäußert?
Er hat gesagt, Windows ist auf jeden Fall besser als Linux, auch wenn er Mac-User ist. Das war ja auch schon 2003, da hatte Linux ja auch noch einen ganz anderen Ruf. Dann haben sie eben diese Wette abgeschlossen und konnten das ja eigentlich nur besiegeln, indem sie eine Usability-Studie durchgeführt haben. Der Jan ist eben auch Besitzer oder Chef einer Usability-Firma und konnte das dann machen. Das war eine sehr große Studie mit 60 Nutzern, wo eben Windows XP versus KDE 3, irgendwas getestet wurde. Alles mit Leuten, die weder Linux noch Windows XP vorher gesehen haben. Und die Ergebnisse waren wirklich...
Ich hab Leute gefunden, die Windows XP noch nicht gesehen haben.
Ja, damals, also das war ja 2002 oder 2003.
Da gab's sowas noch, ok.
Das waren also Leute noch 1998, 1995, wenn ich mich da so...
Ja, teilweise.
Wobei, mich könntet ihr da auch einladen. So wenig Erfahrung.
Na und auf jeden Fall waren die Ergebnisse der Studie also sehr überraschend für den Jan, für die Jutta nicht so. Also die Linux war nicht wirklich schlechter als...
Also Linux im Sinne von KDE als Oberfläche.
Genau, als Oberfläche, also mit grafischer Oberfläche. War nicht wirklich schlechter von den Performance-Daten und auch Akzeptanz-Daten, die da erhoben worden sind. Und mit diesen Ergebnissen wurden dann der KDE-Community bei der Academy, oder die hieß damals noch nicht Academy, über der KDE-Konferenz vorgestellt.
Der Test dann auch noch mal mit dem macOS noch mal aufgenommen worden, oder?
Nein, das nicht, aber... Das hätte ich ja jetzt besonders interessant gefunden. Und die KDE-Community hat dann gesagt, oh ja, so etwas hätten wir gerne noch mehr, noch mehr Usability.
Das fanden sie gut.
Ja, das fanden sie super, genau. Einfach das ein bisschen noch auszuweiten und zu professionalisieren. Und dann kam eben die Idee, so eine Plattform zu gründen, wo Usability-Leute sich registrieren können, wenn sie ein Interesse haben, an Open-Source-Projekten mitzumachen. Und das eben nicht nur KDE dann anzubieten, sondern eben der gesamten Open-Source-Welt, sodass eben sich bei Open-Usability auch alle möglichen anderen Open-Source-Projekte registrieren können und diese Vermittlung dann zwischen Usability-Experten und Projekten...
Also ist es mehr so eine Jobbörse?
Ja, eigentlich schon. Genau, also so war es gedacht.
Man geht jetzt weniger als Gruppe da vor.
Ist das eigentlich eine Partnervermittlung?
Ja, eigentlich eine Partnervermittlung.
Das ist ja auch sehr populär im Internet.
Open-Source-Projekte, Usability-Specials.
Genau, und in dieser Gründungsphase, als wir dann die Plattformen gestartet haben, da kam ich dann dazu. Also vorher war das von Jan und Jutta eine interne Wette.
Okay, Peter, jetzt sollten wir vielleicht noch ein bisschen auf deine Perspektive eingehen. Seit wann setzt du dich mit solchen Themen auseinander?
Na ja, wie bist du dazu gekommen? Lass mal anfangen. Im Gegensatz zur Psychologie habe ich Physik und Informatik studiert. Das zeigt schon einen anderen Blickpunkt an. Während meines Studiums habe ich dann entdeckt, und das war über den Macintosh. Wir sprechen Ende 80er, Anfang 90er Jahren. Ja, das User Interface war doch das Thema, was mich immer faszinierte. Und dann habe ich daraus meinen Beruf gemacht. Ich habe in den Anfangsjahren sehr viel programmiert, ex Windows. Aber ich habe immer gemerkt, dass in diesen Engineering-Umgebungen allen sprachen, dass es doch einfach zu bedienen sein muss. Aber dass ich mit meinen Ansichten und auch mit dem Einblick, in was es das wirklich macht, doch der Einzige im Gebäude war, der es wirklich verstanden hat. Wenn ich es so krass sagen darf.
Wer war der Einzige, der es verstanden hat?
Ich selber.
Du warst der Einzige, der es verstanden hat.
Weil der Rest ist auf einem Ebenen von Engineering-Ansicht gehalten und nie in die Tiefe gehen konnte. Also, nach einer Weile habe ich mich dann entschieden, auch über verschiedene Contracting-Jobs, die ich gemacht habe und die Chance habe, zum Beispiel in der Handyindustrie, AIG-Mobile und Nokia-Mobile, da wirklich grundsätzlich auf Papier an die Struktur von Bedienungen zu arbeiten. Wie setzt man in der allgemeinen, ganzen Architektur auf, und zwar nicht in der technischen, aber in der konzeptuellen Architektur, vor der Bedienung von dem ganzen Handy. Und habe ich bemerkt, dass das Thema mich am meisten Freude macht. Und dass ich eigentlich nur das machen möchte. Ich habe das Engineering verabschiedet und mich darauf konzentriert, wirklich diese konzeptuelle Sachen zu machen.
Das heißt, im Gegensatz zu Ellen, die jetzt diesen empirischen Ansatz hat, man muss mit den Usern reden und mal gucken, was sie wirklich benutzen, was sie wirklich brauchen, und dann schreiben wir das alles auf und gucken mal, was in der Summe bei rauskommt, gehst du mehr so von diesem kathedralen Ansatz? Ich bin jetzt hier der Papst und ich entwickle jetzt mal von oben herab eine Struktur.
Na, lass mal erzählen, wie das eigentlich zusammengreift. Wie in jedes wissenschaftliche Prozess gibt es Vorabwahrnehmung, zum Beispiel in der Physik, verschiedene Sachen in der Natur oder in Experimente werden wahrgenommen, das sind Experimente, ist empirisch, da wird viel gesammelt und da muss man gerne eine Erklärung dafür haben und da wird da eine Theorie gemacht. Die Theorie macht der Theoretiker, das ist ein Konzeptteil, das sitzt da in der Mitte. Diese Theorie muss bewiesen werden, dass es wirklich so ist, wieder mit Experimenten, das ist Wiederwahrnehmung und das ist in unserem Teil wieder Usability-Testing, was eine Validierung von einem Bedienungskonzept ist. Und so greift das gut zusammen und wie es in der Physik einfach Leute gibt, die glücklich sind in der Theorie oder glücklich sind, wenn sie an einen Experiment schamen, gibt es auch die Teilung zwischen Konzepten.
Gibt es jedenfalls auch einen passenden Experten. Das heißt, es bedarf auch wirklich mehrerer Leute, um so ein System wirklich benutzbar zu machen am Ende. Also kann ein Einzelner alle Bereiche abdecken?
Es sind bestimmt Spezialisten, die die beiden Theme so abdecken, aber genau wie es meistens auch mehrere Programmierer brauchen, um ein bisschen größeres System zusammenzuschauen, ist eine Teilung von diesen Tasks und auch es ist sowieso besser, um mit zwei Spezialisten an diesem Thema zu arbeiten als ein. Und wenn es da wirklich so unterschiedliche Blickpunkte gibt, dann kann aus der Diskussion und der Fakt, dass man sich doch wieder genau versteht, das Ergebnis nur besser werden.
Also wir hatten da mal den Begriff gesicherte Innovation eingeführt. Also das heißt, die Zusammenarbeit zwischen Konzeption und Empirie, also dass da zwei unterschiedliche Partner dran arbeiten, ist umso wichtiger, je innovativer das Produkt ist. Also es gibt eben Standardprodukte. Da kann Peter eigentlich ohne einen Usability-Test ein sicheres Konzept machen, ein sicheres Design machen. Genauso kann ich auch ohne ein anspruchsvolles Konzept auch einfache Seiten entwerfen, das Interaktionsdesign. Je innovativer oder komplexer das Ganze wird, umso wichtiger ist es, dass wir wieder zusammenarbeiten und sich jeder auf sein Fachgebiet zurückführen.
Innovation heisst Risiko nehmen, weil man macht etwas ganz Neues. Und es ist auch Innovation, was antreibt für Software statt nur mehr Features, dass es wirklich besser zu bedienen wird und dass das Thema iPhone wirklich mal total anders ist als vorher. Aber das ist Risiko nehmen und das möchte man absichern, durch einerseits auf der richtigen Grundlage aufzubauen. Das ist dieses Grundlagen schaffen, was der MPRI macht. Und zweitens, nachher möchte man validieren, dass man auf der richtigen Spur ist. Und je schneller man anfängt mit Validieren, man kann schauen, wenn der Bleistift auf Papier in dieser Phase ist, je schneller man da Rückkupplung machen kann und mit mehreren Tests das Konzept richten kann, sodass es immer noch innovativ ist und nicht noch nicht mehr sicher zurückgeht. Aber man sicher weiß, jetzt ist es offensichtlich besser.
Gibt es denn so ein paar generell anwendbare Erkenntnisse, so aus dem, was er bisher gemacht hat, wo man sagen kann, jedes Programm sollte grundsätzlich diese drei oder vier Dinge richtig machen? Sonst kann man das sowieso vergessen? Oder hängt es einfach immer vom jeweiligen Fall ab?
Ich würde sagen, das Letzte. Es ist immer das Umfeld, wo man arbeitet. Die Nutzergruppen sind sowieso eine Fokussierung, um zu sagen, außer wenn man von Operating Systems spricht, hey, diese Anwendung ist für ganze breite Gruppen. Wir müssen unsere Urlaubsfotos eigentlich aussortieren und leicht bearbeiten. Oder dass hier ist wie GIMP Software für den Profi oder den Hardcore-User. Da muss man wirklich reinstecken, da muss man sein Lehrgeld bezahlen, um das Ding zu benutzen zu können. Aber dann ist es super effizient, um unglaublich viele Sachen damit zu machen und seine Ideen so schnell wie möglich auszuführen. Und so kann man sehen, dass von diesem Umfeld es sehr abhängt, was da das Beste ist oder die besten Guidelines ist, die man da machen kann.
Also ich sehe das ein bisschen anders. Na ja, also Usability beschäftigt sich ja auch mit einem viel niedrigeren Niveau, als das der Peter tut. Der Peter guckt sich halt Interaktionsdesign an. Das ist ja eine Stufe höher in dem ganzen Usability-Bereich als einfache Dinge wie zum Beispiel Guideline-Verletzungen. Also dass der Kontrast zwischen Schriftfarbe und Hintergrund nicht hoch genug ist. Oder dass das Navigationsschema, also dass es ein Aufklappmenü gibt oder Dinge in der Art. Also das sind einfach so grundlegende Dinge, wo wir als Usability-Leute halt schon sagen, halte dich an die API deiner Umgebung. Also wenn du Software entwickelst, halte dich an, erstens mal verwende die API richtig und zum anderen halte dich an die Guidelines, die da eben gegeben werden. Wenn du im Webbereich bist, dann überleg dir erstmal, welche Elemente du insgesamt brauchst und schreib dir die auf und setze die immer wieder konsistent ein, weil die Konsistenz eben auch sehr wichtig ist. Und das ist extrem viel Arbeit für Usability-Leute, immer durch Webseiten durchzugehen und diese Mini-Dinge rauszusuchen, wo man immer sagt, eigentlich, wenn sie von vornherein, als ich das mal aufgeschrieben hätte, wie es konsistent durchgeführt werden kann, dann hätten wir uns die Arbeit sparen können und auch viel Geld, um das nachträglich zu ändern, was halt wirklich keinen Beitrag zum Interaktionsdesign hat und damit zum guten, zu der Usability auf dieser höheren Ebene, sondern einfach nur stört beim Durchgehen, wenn eben ein Link ständig anders aussieht oder ein Dialog ständig anders funktioniert oder eben ähnliche Interaktionsmuster immer in einer unterschiedlichen Weise umgesetzt sind.
Da kann ich mir großen Tausend bei anschließen, außer mit den kleinen Ausnahmen, dass das Thema Konsistenz und Engineers ist ganz gefährlich. Und da kann man wieder zusammenfassen von, ja, Konsistenz ist im Allgemeinen sehr gut, außer wenn es den Usability wieder verletzt. Und das kann man wieder passieren, wenn man Konsistenz mit einer eiseren Faust durchzieht, weil in bestimmten Fällen kann der Engineer nicht mehr sehen, dass es grundlegend, aber subtil, dass der Usage anders ist und man abweichen muss von dem, was man versucht, durch die ganze Applikation zu stampfen.
Kannst du da mal ein Beispiel geben, weil das ja jetzt doch eine recht abstrakte Sichtweise ist. Was ist denn so ein klassischer Fehler in dem Zusammenhang? Was ist denn zu viel Vereinheitlichung, die dann letztlich stört?
Ein Beispiel ist, dass es schon in jedem GUI Toolkit verschiedene Elemente gibt, wie Checkboxes, Radio-Buttons, kleine Aufklappmenüs, oder vielleicht verschiedene Buttons, die man nebeneinander pushen kann, wo von einem eingedrückt bleibt, um eine Auswahl zu treffen. Wie möchte ich meine Schrift links, rechts oder mittig haben? Und wenn man da mit eiseren Faust weitergeht und sagt, hey, für eine Auswahl aus drei Optionen machen wir immer so ein kleiner Aufklappmenü, wo der Auswahl dann gezeigt wird, wenn es zugeklappt ist, da kann man einfach verletzen, so in diesem Fall von Schrift-Alignment, also links, rechts, mittig, dass es einfach besser ist, da ein paar Eigens nebeneinander zu machen. Aber wenn man wirklich mit den engineering-Gedanken jetzt weiter macht und sagt, für jede Auswahl aus drei oder mehr machen wir so ein kleiner Menü, dann kann jetzt jeder schon nachvollziehen, ja, bei der Schrift ist es doch anders. Aber ich spreche täglich mit Engineers, die in anderen Fällen, die dann nicht so offensichtlich sind, wo ich gegen vier Engineers sagen muss, hey, guck mal bei der Sache, das ist doch doof, wenn wir es so machen, aber mit diesen, wir machen alles, alles muss einheitlich sein, muss man sich dann stundenrund kämpfen.
Wie läuft denn so deine Erfahrung nach die Kommunikation mit den Engineers? Jetzt hast du ja selber auch so einen ähnlichen Hintergrund.
Ja, das hilft.
Das hilft, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Also sicherlich hilfreich, wenn man schon mal die gleiche Sprache spricht. Aber wie ist denn so die Akzeptanz? Also sehen die das dann auch immer ein oder denken die sich, oh Gott, scheiße, jetzt kommt schon wieder dieser Interaktions-Haini und der dreht mir in meinem Code herum, jetzt kann ich gleich wieder alles nochmal neu schreiben?
Na, das kann man total zurückführen und da kann man eigentlich Ellen auch überzählen über die allgemeine Akzeptanz von Usability und Interaktionsdesign in den ganzen Software-Engineering. Und dann kann man im Allgemeinen sagen, Open Source oder Kommerziell, nicht hoch, nur in Ausnahme fallen, ist mein, vor allem wenn du zu mehr spezialisierten Industrien gehst, also mehr vertikale Software wie für Fertigungsindustrie oder solche Sachen oder den Grafikindustrie. Da, wenn du spezialisiert bist, wird je weniger der Akzeptanz überhaupt von einer Mischung von außen, wie das dann gesehen wird. Also ein grosser Streit oder einen grossen Kampf, den wir noch mindestens zehn Jahre dauern, ist, dass es da im Allgemeinen von selber spricht, dass wenn man sich Software baut, dass man da Spezialisten einsetzt vor das Konzept und überhaupt vor diese Schnittstelle mit Menschen, dass da halt Usability-Specialisten beigekommen und dass da untersucht werden muss. So wie von selbst sprechen, das ist, dass wenn man ein Haus baut, dann wenn es kein Showing ist, dann kommt dann ein Architekt dabei. Kein Bürogebäude wird gebaut ohne Architekt. Kein Baufirma fängt da an ohne Pläne. So wird beim Softwarebauen einfach gesagt, naja, die Engineers setzen sich vielleicht noch zusammen mit ein paar Usern und wir bauen uns einfach das Äquivalent von einem Flughafen. In Kompliziertheit, was ein grosses Softwaresystem eigentlich ist.
Heißt das, dass der Interaktionsdesigner oder auch der Usability-Experte, oder in der Personalunion vielleicht beides, so etwas ist wie der Architekt eines Hauses?
Das ist meine zentrale These und so. So ähnlich auch mein Beruf an mit dem von Architekten im Bauen. Und es hat auch Aspekte von sowieso mal zwischen diesen Gruppen von der eigentliche Endkunde, dem User, dem Management, die diesen Bauen eigentlich finanziert und da seine Plenart, warum sie das machen, den Engineers, den Grafiker, also Dekorateurs, da ist eine Architektrolle dafür zu sorgen, dass die überhaupt mal zusammen miteinander reden können. Das ist pure Übersetzung. Und das ist da das ganze Konzept von, lasst das Haus oder diese Software funktionieren für Menschen, nicht nur technisch, dass es stehen bleibt, nicht einstürzt, nicht abstürzt, aber wirklich, dass diese Funktionalität, die es da gibt, dass die von Menschen wahrgenommen wird, einsetzbar ist und auch effizient zu benutzen ist.
Wenn wir bei dem Gleichnis mal bleiben, finde das ja ganz interessant. Üblicherweise ist ja so, dass der Architekt dann auch derjenige ist, der sozusagen der erste und der letzte ist, der an diesem Projekt Hand anlegt und auch in der Regel den gesamten Bauvorgang überwacht.
Das hört sich sehr gut an eigentlich.
Naja, ich meine, ist das dann auch so, quasi der Software anzu...
Es ist sowieso mit Usability und Interaktionsdesign je früher, je besser. Wenn Code schon geschrieben ist, dann fängt es schon an, sicher von den Engineers, dass der Form für den Code, so der Einteilung in Sourcefiles und Funktionen und so weiter, es implizit sehr vorschreibt, wie da noch vorgegangen wird, um es zu verbessern. Und ich habe selbst, wenn ich selbst ein bisschen Code schreibe, dass all mein Wissen flöten geht. Und das erste, was ich versuche, ist, was so mal einfach zu machen ist, durch innerhalb von Funktionen und einem Blog, einfach was umzuändern. Das ist sehr stark, das ist eine unglaublich starken Kraft. Der Außenseiter, derjenige, der sagen kann, hey, wir machen jetzt mal ein Konzept auf Papier und dann besprechen wir, wie es umsetzbar ist, hat er, und das ist Ellen und das ist ich, hat man da Steina Fischstärke und zu sagen, ok, grundsätzlich ist das falsch und ok, das sieht erstmals aus, als ob man da viel umkrempeln muss, aber am Ende, unterm Strich, war es ganz kleine Änderungen, die dadurch den großen Unterschied machen. Aber das Durchdenken fragt erstmal um einen großen Bogen, um sich alles mal in Frage zu stellen, damit du zurückzukommen, ok, was ist jetzt praktisch machbar?
Ich hatte vor ein paar Tagen hier bei Chaosradio Express in der englischen Variante ein Interview mit Dan Kaminsky, der so ein Security-Researcher ist. Da haben wir im Prinzip über was Ähnliches gesprochen, weil nämlich auch Security genauso ein Aspekt ist, der natürlich in der Softwareentwicklung grob vernachlässigt wird und der wie ein schlechtes User-Interface auch sehr schwer im Nachhinein wiederherzustellen ist und im Prinzip von vornherein mit geplant werden muss. Würdet ihr dann auch sagen, dass es eigentlich sinnvoll wäre, dass wenn man sich ein Programmierteam aufbaut, dass man da sowohl einen Security-Experten als auch einen Usability-Experten als Teil des Teams immer mit einplant? Oder ist das wirklich so eine Architektenrolle im Sinne von einem Supervisor? Also was für ein Workflow würdet ihr da sozusagen empfehlen? Also ich hole mir jetzt Kohle ran. Ich habe jetzt irgendwie einen Start-up und ich habe auch eine coole Idee für eine Software. Ich habe jetzt auch eine im Kopf, die sage ich nicht, aber so, jetzt habe ich mir irgendwie meine drei Coding-Slaves zusammengehakt. Was muss ich da jetzt noch mit reintun? Einen Security-Experten habe ich schon. Wie mache ich das mit dem?
Also erstmals, du bautest etwas Neues. Also du baust nicht um.
Was super Innovatives übrigens.
Genau, das Erste ist, du machst dich ein Produkt. Du hast eine Vision, was das bringen soll, warum es sich überhaupt lohnt, darin zu investieren. Entweder bist du jetzt selbst der Product-Manager oder du holst dich schon ein Product-Manager, der das Produkt ausarbeiten und weiter, da kommt der Vertrieb am Ende dabei, der Vernetzung in der ganzen Softwareindustrie oder in den Zielgruppen kommt auch schon mal dabei. Das ist ein Punkt, wo ich zum Beispiel aufbauen kann. Den Punkt von, was ist der Nutzen von diesem Softwareprodukt? Das Innovative, was bringt das an Mehrwert vor Endnutzer? Und wie können wir diesen Mehrwert-Umsetzung, und das passiert immer über den Interface, weil die Mehrwert-Umsetzung geht über User, wie können wir das wirklich verwirklichen? Und das ist für mich der Anfangspunkt. Dann kann man sich empirisch die richtigen Grundlagen holen. Also diesen Gruppen von User, wie tecken die? Wie arbeiten die? Wie denken die? Und wo sind wirklich die Handlungen, wo man sich Effizienzverbesserungen oder mit total neuen Workflows, wo man unglaublich viel, nur nach 15, Arbeit aushandeln nimmt, wo man wirklich wieder Mehrwert schaffen kann? Also da geht Ellen empirisch zum Gruppen dahin. Und dann kann man wirklich sagen, ok, ein Interface basiert auf diesen Fakten, lass uns ein Modell machen für diesen Interface, wie man da wirklich diesen rausgefundenen Workflows, zusammen mit diesem Mehrwert, Zielsetzung, wie man das verwirklichen kann. Und dann kann man anfangen, auf Papiere einfach das in Form zu geben.
Aber meine Frage war eher so, kann diese Usability durch einen Berater, der dann ab und zu mal vorbeikommt, wieder Firmenmasseur geleistet werden, oder muss der Teil des Teams sein, über den vollständigen Entwicklungszeitpunkt hinweg?
Also es kommt natürlich ein bisschen auf die Größe des Teams an und wie viel da produziert wird, wenn das jetzt nur drei Entwickler sind und kaum Code entwickelt wird. Dann reicht das, wenn der Berater ab und zu kommt. Also was besonders wichtig ist, dass der Berater immer Bescheid weiß, was die Pläne sind und was gerade entwickelt wird. Also dass alle Fäden bei dem Berater zusammenlaufen. Ja genau, und vorab Pläne gemacht. Das heißt, das war immer ein großes Problem in KDE zum Beispiel, dass das Projekt so groß ist, dass die fünf Usability-Leute gar nicht mehr wussten, was an den verschiedenen Ecken passiert. Und man deswegen auch erst eingreifen konnte, wenn es schon zu spät war.
Es ist auch sehr ätzend, da im Feuerwehrmodus rumzugehen und immer wieder, wenn ja Code schon steht, dann mal den Disco schon anfangen zu müssen, von das taucht grundsätzlich nicht.
Genau, deswegen, genau. Es ist eben klar, je größer das Team ist und je größer die Software ist, die da entsteht, umso wichtiger ist es, dass man eben Usability-Leute als feste Bestandteile des Teams hat. Und wenn das ein kleines Produkt ist, dann reicht es auch, wenn da vielleicht einmal pro Woche vorbeikommt.
Und da sprengt man eigentlich auch von dem Modus, in dem der Entwicklungsteam arbeitet. Manche Firmen, klein oder groß, gehen da unglaublich amtlich vor. Mit Spezifikationen, mit Ausarbeiterrequirements. Das ist unabhängig davon, wie groß das Team ist, weil auch in Riesenfirmen sind die Teams am Ende fünf Leute groß, oder eine Kombination von Teams von fünf Leuten eigentlich. Andererseits gibt es totalen Chaos, auch bei den Riesenfirmen, wo jeder einfach macht und der Code ist die einzige Dokumentation. Und das wächst organisch von selber. Und in diesem Umfeld muss der Spezialist sich auch anpassen, irgendwie Griff drauf bekommen und da reinpassen eigentlich. Aber immer doch anfangen anzusteuern, statt Feuer zu löschen.
Wir haben schon mehrfach erwähnt, es gab ja jetzt auch gerade im Kontext des Open-Useability-Projektes verschiedene Zusammenarbeiten. Du hast jetzt eben schon die Arbeit mit KDEW erwähnt. Vielleicht steigen wir damit mal ein. Was ist da bisher passiert? Wie sah diese Zusammenarbeit aus? Wie ist es dazu gekommen und was hat das so für Ergebnisse?
Na ja, KDEW war ja das erste Projekt, wie ich vorhin schon gesagt hatte. Also durch diesen KDE-Useability-Test ist Open Usability eben sehr stark mit KDE auch verwurzelt. Wir betreuen sicher auch noch eine Menge andere Projekte, auch eben Usability-Leute, die wir gar nicht kennen, die sich dann irgendwie mit anderen Projekten zusammengetan haben, eben im Rahmen dieser Kontakt-Börse, also Open Usability. Aber der Fokus jetzt wirklich der Berliner Leute, die eben von dieser Usability-Firma Relevantive kamen, der war doch sehr stark bei KDE. Und da haben wir eben am Anfang einzelne Anwendungen.
Das ist jetzt dieser Usability-Stammtisch hier in Berlin?
Nein, das ist nicht der Stammtisch. Das ist die Usability-Firma, die Open Usability gegründet hat. Aber dann gab es einen Manpower-Gestellten.
Eine der Organisationsformen des Open Usability-Projektes war dieser Stammtisch.
Ja, der wurde jetzt zusammengelegt mit dem Stammtisch der UPA, also der Berufsverband Usability in Deutschland. Wir treffen uns jetzt im New Thinking, und das ist mehr so vortragsmäßig. Der Stammtisch im Chaos Computer Club damals, der von Open Usability war, der war eher als Praxisansatz, dass eben Open Source-Projekte kommen und uns ihre Software vorstellen. Und wir gemeinsam dann eben mal eine Evaluation machen. Oder uns bestimmt, wenn sie eben ein neues Feature konzipiert haben, dass wir uns eben zusammengesetzt haben und überlegt haben, wie muss das aussehen und eben da auch mit dem Konzept gemacht haben.
Genau diesen Jahr, wo das gelaufen ist, war das Grundlegend für die ganze Season of Usability, diesen Projekten zu machen. Für meine Zusammenarbeit mit der GIMP zum Beispiel, war es total, sich zu nähern und das Vertrauen zu haben, anzufangen, hat er unglaublich dazu beigetragen. Obwohl es jetzt wieder verschwunden ist oder zusammengelegt mit etwas anderes, war es doch eine Phase, die sehr notwendig war, um weiterzukommen.
Ja, war auf jeden Fall super, war nur ein bisschen zu oft. Wir hatten das zweimal im Monat und da war dann irgendwann auch die Luft draußen. Also weder Open-Source-Entwickler hatten Lust, da noch ständig hinzukommen, noch wir als Usability-Leute. Das war einfach ein bisschen zu viel. Und der neue Stammtisch ist jetzt einmal pro Monat und ist schon auch so gedacht.
Mehr so auf Präsentationsbasis.
Ja, also schon auch gedacht, dass man da mal praktische Dinge macht oder sich Rat von den anderen holt, aber schon etwas formeller, also auch etwas geplanter, vielleicht auch seriöser, wahrscheinlich.
Jetzt habe ich eben noch ein bisschen abgelenkt. Vielleicht noch mal zu KDE. KDE, die Zusammenarbeit. Also damals wurde KDE 3 noch getestet.
Genau.
Neure Version ist vielleicht egal.
Ja, bis vor einem halben Jahr ja auch noch.
Jetzt, gerade vor zwei Tagen, ist ja die Version 4.0 rausgekommen. Da ist eine Menge Arbeit reingeflossen. Ich hab da auch schon vor einem Jahr mich, glaube ich, mal mit einem KDE-Menschen unterhalten. Hier ist es auch gleich real soon now. Dann hat es wohl dann doch noch ein bisschen länger gedauert. Habt ihr dazu auch was beigetragen?
Na, wir haben an einzelnen Anwendungen mitgearbeitet, wie zum Beispiel Dolphin, das ist der neue Dateimanager, der den Conqueror ablöst, der jetzt nur noch zum reinen Dateimanagement ist. Also nicht mehr diese eierlegende Wollmilchshause. Oder wie Conqueror vorher. Conqueror soll jetzt eben nur noch eine reine Web-Browsing-Funktion haben. Und Okular, das ist der neue PDF und Image-Viewer. Da hat der Florian Kressler auch von Open-Use-Ability sehr viel Arbeit reingesteckt. Und wir haben eben angefangen, User-Interface-Guidelines zu schreiben für KDE 4. Das ist aber auch ein Projekt, das leider so von einem dreiviertel Jahr ein bisschen versandet ist, da Celeste und ich kaum noch Zeit haben, weil wir beide beruflich gerade ziemlich stark eingespannt sind. Aber naja, das ist ja auch nur das 4.0er-Release. Auch technisch muss noch viel gemacht werden an KDE. Und das wird sich sicher wieder...
Wie sah denn diese Zusammenarbeit konkret aus? Vielleicht noch ein Beispiel rausgreifen, dieses Okular, dieser Viewer. Also was habt ihr denn dabei? Habt ihr denn jetzt wirklich Tests gemacht oder habt ihr nur Empfehlungen geschrieben oder Guidelines gemacht?
Also zum einen wurden da Tests durchgeführt, schon früher mit dem Vorgängermodell KPDF Viewer. Da hatten wir damals bei ReLeVentive auch eine kleine Nutzerstudie gemacht, um eben erstmal die größten Probleme rauszufinden, auch zu hören, was sind die Anforderungen. Was jetzt wirklich in konzeptioneller Arbeit in Okular umgesetzt worden ist, das war größtenteils ohne empirische Grundlage. Da wir im Moment eben weniger Mittel haben, um Nutzerstudien durchzuführen oder die Räumlichkeiten fehlen und die Manpower ein bisschen.
Das heißt dann schon mehr Interaktionsdesign?
Ja, mehr Interaktionsdesign. Florian hat einen Kommunikationshintergrund und ist stärker auch gestalterisch orientiert. Er hat eben dann auch mit Okular ein Season of Usability-Projekt gestartet. Season of Usability ist ähnlich wie Google Summer of Code. Nur, dass statt Informatik- und Usability-Studenten für die Dauer von ca. drei Monaten an einem Open-Source-Projekt mitarbeiten und dabei von einem Usability-Mentor geleitet werden.
Gibt es da auch Geld?
Da gibt es auch Geld, nicht ganz so viel. 700 Dollar für den Studenten und dann 150 jeweils für das Projekt. Letztes Jahr bei der Season of Usability kam das vom Open Society-Institut. Das ist so ein gemeinnütziges Institut in Ungarn basiert. Und dieses Jahr kommt das teilweise noch von Google, auch noch vom Open Society-Institut und dann noch von...
Projekte selber, Open Printing sponsert sein eigenes...
Open Printing sponsert sein eigenes Drupal, sponsert sein eigenes Projekt, also Civic Actions, über Civic Actions.
Das heißt, ihr bemüht euch dann auch aus Open Usability heraus. Also ist das jetzt sozusagen ein von Open Usability getragenes Projekt, dieses Season?
Es ist von Open Usability organisiert.
Okay, das heißt ihr kümmert euch auch mit darum, Sponsoren zu finden. Und wenn jemand das toll findet, dann könnt ihr sich an euch wenden, wenn er irgendwo ein bisschen Geld rumpen hat.
Sponsoren werden immer gebraucht.
Das ist klar.
Was wäre denn jetzt bei dem Okular anders gewesen, wenn es keine Usability-Beratung gegeben hätte? Also welchen Einfluss, ich weiß, das ist schwer zu sagen, aber was meinst du, wo es wirklich einen Impact gehabt hat?
Also was der Florian vor allem gemacht hat, war eben diesen Annotations-Bereich neu zu gestalten und den Toolbar neu zu gestalten. Und wenn man sich halt den Toolbar, also die Werkzeugleiste von KPDF anschaut, ist die so einfach suboptimal. Also die Zooming-Funktionen sind nicht so wirklich ganz intuitiv zu nutzen. Das Weiterblättern ist nicht so richtig gut. Also der Florian ist da einfach konzeptionell rangegangen, hat sich überlegt, wenn man sich einen PDF anschaut, was brauche ich da in der Werkzeugleiste? Wenn ich mir ein Bild anschaue, was brauche ich dann? Und ist eben da auch Use-Case basiert rangegangen. Ich sagte, okay, die Nutzer, wenn die einen PDF anschauen, brauchen sie das und das und das. Und hat es eben dann umgesetzt. Und ähnlich ist er auch bei den Annotations vorgegangen. Wenn die Entwickler das eben alleine gemacht hätten, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit groß, dass sie halt viel featuregetriebener vorgegangen wären. Wir sagten, okay, wir brauchen halt ein Zooming und wir brauchen Annotations. Und sie eben einfach irgendwie umgesetzt hätten.
Bam, bam, bam, alles voll klatschen. Da sind noch 20 Pixel Platz, da geht noch was rein.
Oder im Zweifelsfall irgendwo abgeguckt hätten und eine schlechte Kopie erstellt hätten.
Ja, ich glaube, mit gutem User-Interface-Design ist es auch ein bisschen wie mit guter grafischer Gestaltung. Wenn man sich so eine Datenschleuder von früher anschaut, das Magazin des CCC, die ersten Ausgaben, da war auch so die Devise, da ist doch noch Weiß auf der Seite, da können wir doch noch was reinschreiben. Ohne dass man das mehr als Datenverlust, anstatt als Raumgewinn und als Leitmittel für den Informationsfluss des Lesers sieht. Ich glaube, das ist auch so ein generelles Problem bei Programmierern, dass sie einfach immer nur getrieben von ihrem Feature-Set und dann eben mit diesem unschlagbaren Vorteil alle diese Features auch wirklich zu kennen und auch zu wissen, warum es die gibt und so weiter, dann einfach loszugehen und zu sagen, ach ja, alles muss irgendwie erschließbar sein.
Ja, ich habe letztens auf der World Usability Day einen Teil über Features da erzählt. Das war ein Umfeld von iPhone, die ein Drittel von den Features von einem normalen oder gangbaren Business-Telefon hat. Und da habe ich so gesagt, na erstens gibt es da einen Teufelskreis zwischen Users und Entwicklern. User sagen immer Ja zu Features, wie Kinder immer Ja zu Süßigkeiten sagen, auch wenn das zum Bauchschmerzen leitet. Und für Features ist es oder für Developer ist das einfachste, um zu zufrieden zu machen ist, mehr Features zu bieten. Weil dann ist es für jeden klar, dass es jetzt besser ist. Oder den Update wert. Und jetzt ist es so, dass wenn man keine blasse Ahnung hat, wie man sein Software eigentlich verbessern kann, kann man immer noch ein paar Features zufügen. Dann muss es wieder besser sein, weil es macht mehr. Und da gewissenhaft sich auf das Wesentliche zu beschränken, da manchmal Features wegzuschneiden, auch wenn das von manchen ein Regression genannt wird, weil plötzlich geht etwas nicht mehr. Aber lass mal so sagen, von Ellen und mir, je mehr Features, je unwahrscheinlicher wird es, um die Bedienung gut, übersichtlich, geschwind und einfach auch einen gewissen Spaß anzubieten bei der Bedienung.
Du hast den World Usability Day erwähnt. Was ist das für eine Veranstaltung?
Es ist eine weltweite Veranstaltung. Es ist ein Tag, wo weltweit aber lokal Veranstaltungen sind, um das Thema Usability in die Bilder zu bringen. Also Aufmerksamkeit darauf zu bringen, das Thema zu verbreiten. Wir brauchen immer noch viele Evangelien, um das zu verbreiten unter Entwicklern und den User. Und wir haben mitorganisiert an den lokalen Veranstaltungen, die gibt es seit drei Jahren jetzt. Es gibt überhaupt keine Usability seit drei Jahren.
Erst seit drei Jahren, ja.
Ich glaube, jedes Jahr war Berlin dabei. Wir organisieren ein Tagesveranstaltungen mit einem Lesungsprogramm. Dieses Jahr auch Workshops. Die waren sehr populär. Und das ist es auch im Kurzen eigentlich.
Und wie wird es auch wieder geben? Aber man weiß ja immer nicht, wann dieser Podcast gehört wird. Vielleicht ist es ja schon wieder Oktober gerade. Ja, ich habe das Datum gar nicht gesagt. Wir sitzen hier am 12. Januar 2008 für die Aliens, die auf diesen Podcast erst 3000 Jahre später gestoßen sind. Ja, 8. November 2007 war der letzte. Da gibt es noch keinen neuen Termin, oder? Muss ja auch nicht sein. Okay. Ach, es gibt so viel Interessantes hier. Bevor wir das vergessen, KDE haben wir jetzt beleuchtet. Peter, du hattest ja auch dann nochmal eine größere Zeitinvestition in das GIMP-Projekt. Das kam in dem Interview mit Sven Neumann über GIMP auch kurz zur Sprache. Vielleicht kannst du ja nochmal sagen, was... GIMP ist ja nun gerade für den Open Source-Bereich so eine Leuchtturmfunktion, weil es ja eigentlich eine der frühesten Anwendungen mit einem User-Interface überhaupt war und in gewisser Hinsicht ja auch durch die Entwicklung von GIMP genommen und damit irgendwie auch eines der ersten User-Interface- Subsysteme für Linux mitgeboren wurde. Was war da dein Beitrag und was hast du da vorgefunden?
Na ja, ich kann wirklich nur sagen, dass ich da nur angefangen bin jetzt. Wir sind jetzt so anderthalb Jahre weiter oder so, seit ich mich da eingesetzt habe. Also der erste Kontakt ist da gelegt bei diesen Open-Use-Ability-Treffen im TTC und mich Sven auch in einem Podcast erzählt.
Heute trinken wir mal nicht Clubmate, heute trinken wir Bionade. Das gehört in Prenzlauer Berg.
Also es war klar, dass Sven als Maintainer war auf der Suche, dass Profis bei dem Projekt dabei kamen, weil GIMP ist stark polarisierend, da muss man nur aufs Web gehen und jedes Mal, wenn GIMP zu Sprache kommt, gibt es da 100 oder 200 Kommentare, wo nie etwas subtilisch steht. Es ist sehr stark polarisierend und das geht von, ja, kann man wunderbar damit alles machen, aber das große Teil ist von, ja, DIY, und solchen Themen wie 16-bit und CYMK. Ja, das haben wir ja schon ausführlich besprochen, das müssen wir nicht wiederholen. So, es gab da eine Reizung und die gibt es in Comercial und in Comercialer Software-Projekte auch von, wir wissen, dass da etwas schief ist, aber wir können die Finger nicht drauf legen, was es dann ist. Holen wir einen Spezialisten dabei. In diesem Fall war so eine Verständnis aufgebaut zwischen Sven und mir, er hat mich kennengelernt, er wusste, dass ich strukturell beitragen konnte zur Software-Entwicklung und dass ich nicht, was er bisher so getroffen hat, irgendwelchen User mit Ideen, die nie so der richtige Richtung gegeben hat. Es gab einfach 100 verschiedene Richtungen von 100 verschiedenen User, wo es hingehen soll. Also kam er in so ein Treffen, kam dazu Sprache, wir diskutierten etwas und in bestimmten Momenten hat er gesagt, einfach gehen, Sven, diese Produkte schon, was ist GIMP eigentlich? Und er sagte, ja, es ist eigentlich eine gute Frage. Und das erste, was wir gemacht haben, war auf so einem Liebherr-Grafics-Kongress mit einem großen Teil von Developers. Und da sind nicht so viele Developers, also eine Gruppe von zwölf Leuten oder so. Es ist einfach, festzunageln in ein paar Statements, was GIMP eigentlich ist. Und damit auch implizit zu sagen, was es da nicht ist und welchen Teilen wir dann auch nicht aktiv und welchen Teilen von der Benutzergruppe wir dann auch nicht primär unterstützen. Also, wenn eine harte Auswahl gemacht werden muss von geht so oder so, dann machen wir nur das vor der Kern Benutzergruppe. Und da kann zum Beispiel die große Gruppe, die doch einmal im Jahr seine Urlaubsfotos damit bearbeiten möchte, kommt damals schlechter weg. Weil GIMP ist ein Power-User-Tool. Genau, da muss man investieren, da muss man sein Lehrgeld bezahlen. Es ist wie Lernen auf ein Musikinstrument zu spielen. Am Anfang, wenn man anfängt, sicher bei Violin oder so, ist das Ergebnis nicht erfreulich. Es ist eher frustrierend. Aber wenn man genug investiert in Zeit, in Üben, in Unterricht, dann beherrscht man das Instrument und kann man sehr schöne Sachen machen. Entweder beruflich oder für sich selbst oder für andere Leute, einfach als Amateur.
Und was kam jetzt dabei raus? Was waren so Änderungen, die aus dieser Interaktion kamen?
Wir sind auf einem sehr langen Weg. Es ist ein riesen, kompliziertes Programm. Und das ist das, was wir viel Zeit daran verbraucht haben. Aber es musste gemacht werden, dass wir als Spezialisten, das war auch in der letzten Podcast erzählt, wie das Team daran arbeitet, wissen, wovon wir reden. Ich bin einfach kein Game-User, und das ist auch besser so, weil dann bin ich objektiver und nicht damit verheiratet, wie ich es bisher war. Wir mussten wissen, wovon wir sprechen, wir mussten den ganzen Funktionalitätsumfang kennen, wir mussten das ganze Ding evaluieren anhand von User-Observer-Showern, die Ellen gemacht hat zusammen mit Camilla. Also wirklich herausfinden, wie ticken die Leute, die es benutzen sollen. Nicht unbedingt alle Leute, die es benutzen, aber wirklich diese Kerngruppe von Leuten. Wie arbeiten die, wie denken die, was sind die Workflows, die sie da so haben. Und was es am Moment gibt, das ist in dem Wiki nachzulesen, da gibt es bestimmt einen Link auch bei diesem Podcast.
Auf jeden Fall.
Erst, dass wir ausarbeiten haben, der Essenz von was es ist. Wir haben mit dem Skim Team in einem späteren Meeting im Essen haben wir ausarbeitet essentielle Workflows, essentielle User-Scenarios, was man damit macht. Und das ist die Basis, womit man so einen Teil evaluieren kann. Man kann nicht einfach durch alles durchgehen, von gefällt das oder nicht. Es geht total nicht um uns, es geht darum. Unterstützt das diesen Workflows, ist das der richtige Level, als Beginnentool oder Profitool vor diesem Bündnis zu gruppen, kann man damit effizient arbeiten. Und bei GIMP, Profitool, liegt die Betonung auf, es ist nicht einfach zu lernen, die Betonung liegt auf, wenn man es gelernt hat, kann man unglaublich effizient, unglaublich powerful damit arbeiten. Dann das erste Praktische, was da gemacht ist, ist, im 2.4 sind ein paar von den Selection Tools und ein Crop Tool ist da redesigned, da haben wir eine Space Vacation geschrieben, ist von einem schwedischen Programmierer, ist das dann umgesetzt. Das ist dann auch eine sehr enge Zusammenarbeit, wo auf den IRC man wirklich sich überlegt, wo klare Programmierer immer sagen, ja das geht doch nicht, oder da in der Space Vacation, da ist ein Loch, oder gibt es einfach einen Böck in der Space Vacation, hier sagst du das, da sagst du das. Aber es gibt noch einen dritten Fall, was passiert dann? Oder es geht doch schief in diesem Fall. So die bückt man diese Space Vacation auch wieder und der wird dann technisch umgesetzt von einem Engineer eigentlich.
Und das hat auch geklappt?
Das hat sehr gut geklappt, diese Zusammenarbeit lief sehr gut. Es war auch klar, dass weil es halt diese Space Vacation überhaupt gab, dass diese Programmierer überhaupt Bock hatten, da anzufangen. Weil man konnte absehen, wie umfangreich es wurde und auch, es stand schon fest, dass dieses Stück Code erstmal mit der Bulldoze drüber gegangen werden musste, was war sehr alt, ein Spaghetti-Code. Und dann ist da etwas neu geschrieben. Und wenn man da vorab sehen kann, oh, das wird es, so wird es funktionieren, so kompliziert wird es. Und diesen Infrastruktur, technisch brauchen wir dafür, dann hilft das auf alle Fälle, aber es hilft auch motivierend.
Wie war denn das Feedback von der Benutzer-Char? Habt ihr da schon welches einsammeln können? Also ein paar werden natürlich wieder laut schreien. Oh Gott, das ist anders als vorher.
Das ist sicher eine Sache bei GIMP, weil genau durch diesen Aspekt von, man muss sich in jedes Aspekt, muss man sich da trainieren, vor das es blendet funktioniert, heißt auch, dass man kann nicht in GIMP-Ed ein Tool total ändern und dann gleich zum User gehen und das einfach testen, ob es dann funktioniert oder nicht. Ellen und ich denken darüber nach, über Methoden, wo man die User erstmal eins oder zwei Monate selbst das lernen lässt. Also durchgezwungen durch ihren oder seinen Job, dass sie das täglich benutzen muss, damit es zurechtkommt oder nicht. Und dann testet es, funktioniert es, blendet es oder nicht. Und eröffnet es neue Wege, um seinen Job zu machen zum Beispiel. Also Akzeptant-Testung bei GIMP ist nicht so einfach. Und wenn 2.4 introduziert ist, muss man auch nicht auf den ersten Tag zuhören, dass die Leute sagen, oh Gott, sie haben es geändert. Aber glücklich, und das hat mich sehr gefreut, von den Feedback, die dadurch durchkommt, von sicher auch bei dem Beta-User, dass Leute, die wirklich ein Profi sind, sagen, ja, mit den Selection-Tools, es ist eine absolute Ehre, wie viel effizienter, wie viel einfacher, oder vor allem, wie viel effizienter ich da arbeiten kann. Und das tut gut, das kann man sagen.
Du arbeitest auch nicht mit GIMP.
Doch, das mach ich schon, aber ich lade mir nie die neuesten Versionen runter, weil die ja immer noch ein bisschen buggy sind und kompilieren vom Source Code, mach ich sowieso nicht selbst.
Ich meine aber auch jetzt eher die Herangehensweise.
Ja, doch, auf jeden Fall.
Davon haben wir die zusammen Formel gegeben.
Vielleicht, was sicherlich auch eine Menge Leute interessiert, das kam jetzt ja auch mal schon mit dem iPhone leicht zur Sprache, hin zu den populären Plattformen. Nun sind ja Windows und der Macintosh dominieren den Desktop und werden das sicherlich auch noch eine ganze Weile lang tun, auch wenn Linux Open Source dort mit einer Rolle spielt. Was sind denn so eure Gedanken zu diesen Betriebssystemen und ihrer Art und Weise, wie sie so auf den Benutzer zukommen? Genau, eine Meinung?
Ja, der Macintosh spielt halt mit dem Joy of Use, was ja gerade Peters Lieblingsthema ist. Deswegen gehe ich gleich wieder an Peter zurück.
Spaß am Gerät.
Spaß am Gerät, genau.
Das klingt doch sehr gut. Was heißt das, dass bei Linux alles total ernst ist?
Man kann so sagen, dass genau wie beim Bauen von Häusern, genau wie man in den 60er Jahren einfach Hochhäuser gebaut hat und sicher in den 70er Jahren, die unglaublich effizient waren, alle hatten Licht, alle hatten gute Räume, alle hatten gute Sanitäre im Haus, alle hatten eine Grünfläche vor der Haustür, wo Kinder spielen konnten. Das Verkehr war getrennt von dieser Spielfläche und von dieser Wohnfläche und so weiter. Das war alles super effizient. Und bisher in diesem Podcast habe ich auch über Effizienz geredet als Ziel von Usability, Gebrauchsteiligkeit. Und genau wie Leute heutzutage, dass das nicht mehr so gebaut wird, also Hochhäuser sind nicht mehr so populär als Lösung, wo sollen Leute wohnen, ist es auch, nachdem das Thema Usability in den letzten 20 Jahren so ausgebaut ist, dass man auch bemerkt, dass wenn man eine bestimmte Applikation einfach super effizient macht, dass sie irgendwie auch total langweilig wird. Und dass dem Joy of Use, was ein anderer Aspekt ist, was eigentlich da orthogonal steht auf der eigentlichen Effizienz, dass das auch mitspielt und dass Leute das brauchen.
Also so spielerische Elemente mit einbauen, Minds creeper.
Es geht nicht um Gimmicks. Es geht da um bestimmte Feinheiten, wie schön, wie elegant Bedienungselemente sich verhalten in einer kleinen Interaktion. Ein Beispiel, was ich da habe, wo ich denke, wo es wirklich spielt, ist zum Beispiel, wenn man ein iPhone durchscrollt und die Scrolling-Liste kommt an zu Ende, macht es so einen kleinen Hupfen.
Es schlägt an. Genau. Wie gegen eine Gummiwand.
Jedes Mal, wenn es passiert, macht es ein kleines Lächeln auf dein Gesicht. Und es wird auch, denke ich, zwei Jahre so bleiben, solange diese Generation weiter. Das ist nicht ein Gimmick, das einfach vergeht. Es braucht auch ein bisschen extra Zeit, aber es ist eine unglaublich kleine Zeit.
Ich finde es vor allem eine interessante Hilfe. Es ist sonst immer sehr schwer, das Ende als solches auch zu erkennen. Man weiß nicht, läuft er jetzt nur aus? Oder bin ich wirklich am Anschlag, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes?
Rainy Usability hat gesagt, mit dem Scrollbar und dem Faktorstück, dass es so steht. Hatte man klar und einfach sehr geradeaus sagen können, habe ich es abgetestet, damit die genügend Leute erkennen, dass die Liste am Ende ist.
Hast du ein iPhone?
Ich habe es nicht, aber ich habe schon vor ein paar Aufträgen evaluieren müssen, weil die Konkurrenz nicht still ist. Ich habe mich sehr mit dem iPhone beschäftigt.
Vielleicht kannst du noch mal ein bisschen dazu sagen, was du beim iPhone vorgefunden hast, weil das wahrscheinlich auch einer der mutigsten Schritte war. Sie haben zwei Drittel der üblichen Funktionalität, die die Leute erwarten, rausgeschmissen. Was macht denn das iPhone richtig und was macht das iPhone falsch?
Ich hab das am World Usability Day in so einer Zehn-Punkte-Liste aufgelistet, warum man aus einem normalen Handy kein iPhone machen kann. Und genau diesen Unterschiede entzählt, die es da gibt, kann man auch in meinem Blog nachlesen.
Kannst du vielleicht mal so ein paar nennen?
Aber das fängt schon an, und das haben wir eigentlich schon vorher besprochen. Wichtigster Faktor ist der Chef. Steve Jobs ist nicht zufrieden, bis die wirkliche Interaktion blendet ist und einfach jedem in den Arsch tritt, bis es so ist. Also, der höchste Person in der Organisation fühlt den Schmerz, wenn es nicht gut genug ist und sorgt davor, dass es ausgeführt wird.
Er ist sozusagen der Architekt.
Er ist nicht der Architekt, er ist der Auftraggeber. Aber er nimmt keinen genügend mit, wenn es nicht einfach sehr gut ist und tritt auch den Architekten im Arsch, bis es wirklich gut ist. Und sagt gegen jeden, jenen Manager, die da unten hängt, man kann jetzt nicht sagen, wenn eine Funktionalität drin ist, gut genug. Nein, es muss blendet sein der Bedienung, weil da kommt es drauf an. Das gilt für jede Organisation, wenn nicht der Chef oder ein VP von einer Riesenorganisation diesen Schmerz fühlt und einen im Arsch tritt, dann kann man es eigentlich schon vergessen mit der Usability. Dann ist es egal, ob ein kleiner Abteilungsleiter einfach sagt, oh, wir holen einen Specialisten drin. Es gibt nicht mehr wieder einen anderen Abteilungsleiter, der damit verbunden ist, der dafür sorgt, dass es nicht umgesetzt wird. Zweitens ist Fission. Was ist das Ding, was ist das Ding nicht? Sie haben einfach gesagt, das Ding ist kein Blackberry-Konkurrent. Also können wir uns das leisten, denn ein Trade-off, das auf so einer riesen Touchscreen, was toll für Media ist, toll für Web-Browsing ist, da kann man einfach nicht so gut tippen. Oder man kann da genauso gut tippen wie auf einem normalen Dialpad. Ich habe das in Amerika gesehen. Das heißt, jemand nehmt mir ein Restaurant und hat ein iPhone und hat einfach so tickticktick ein SMS getippt. Ich dachte, war doch nicht schlecht. Und das geht dann zum Beispiel über diese ein Drittel Features ist da ein Faktor, dass sie sich auf das Wesentliche konzentriert haben, dass sie sich nicht von den Telefongesellschaften vorschreiben haben, dass alle 200 Features drin sein müssen, plus noch ein bisschen extra. MMS haben sie einfach so in den Tisch lassen fallen und so weiter für Bilder verschicken. Stimmt auch, macht fast niemand. Und es geht weiter mit Integration von Hardware und Software, dass es aussieht, als ob es aus einem Guss kommt. Dann ist diesen holistischen Ansatz, wenn man iPhone obwohl da Dutzende von Leuten gearbeitet haben, kommt doch diese starken Top-Down-Leitung, die Steve Jobs rangegeben hat. Und wo jedes Detail von ihm überprüft wird, sorgt das vor, dass das ganze Gerät, man findet immer ein paar Boxen in Interactionen und so weiter, aber im Ganzen holistisch ist. Es fühlt, als ob es aus einem Guss gemacht ist, von einer Person. Klar, das geht nicht, aber es fühlt so an. Und das ist auch ein Schlüssel zum Einfachkeit. Dass es einfach zu bedienen anfühlt. Und das insgesamt, das sind so ein paar Punkte, die ich so mal ausdenken.
Okay, aber das ist ja eine sehr allgemeine Betrachtung der Umstände, unter denen das Gerät sozusagen entstanden ist. Ich meine, wenn man sich mal ganz konkret die Benutzerführung anschaut, was ist da jetzt konkret gelungen? Was macht das iPhone an der Stelle dann auch besser als andere Telefone?
Da muss man auch noch dabei gesagt werden, dass wenn man es wirklich anschaut, ist das iPhone eine Art Trojanis Pferd. Es steht drauf, dass es ein Telefon ist, aber eigentlich ist es ein Communication-Tablet, das zufällig auch noch GSM-Calls macht und SMS'en verschickt. Eigentlich ist es eine total neue Art von Geräten, das damit geschaffen ist. Es steht auch weit weg von jedem anderen GSM-Telefon, was man gemacht hat. Man kann es auch nicht so einfach durch ein Telefon zu verbessern. Man kann besser aus einer anderen Ecke mit Zufügen von Telefonfunktionen dahin kommen, wo das iPhone eigentlich ist. Aber sie benutzen klar die großen Bildflächen, die sie da haben. Die Bildfläche ist fast so groß wie der Original Macintosh. Das ist wie ein früherer PC, so groß ist das. Früher hat man auf diesem Macintosh mal Zeitungen gemacht und so weiter. Desktop Publishing Revolution ist darauf losgegangen. So einen großen Bildschirm hat es. Sie sind nicht in der Falle gelaufen, dass andere Touchscreen-Geräte, dass man ein Mobile-Telefon-Interface genommen hat. Das ist ein bisschen abgeendet von Touchscreen und fertig. Man ist einfach grundlegend von der anderen Seite gekommen und hat gesagt, okay, wie kann man, da man freigestalten kann auf Touchscreen, was kann man da machen? Sie sind auch nicht darauf gelaufen, dass dieser kleine Touchscreen dasselbe ist als einen grossen Desktop auf dem Büro. Sie haben erkannt, dass es seine eigene Welt ist, hat seine eigene Stärke, es hat seine eigene Schwachkeiten und haben daraus diesen Touchscreen-UI aufgebaut, wo es große Knöpfe gibt, um drauf zu drücken. Meistens beschriftet mit großem Text und einem grossen Icon. Dass sie freigestalten können, viel Raum geben an Content, an Multimedia-Content, dass sie den Risiko genommen haben, zum Beispiel bei Fotos anschauen, da gibt es keine Indikationen, von hier kannst du zoomen. Das kannst du mit zwei Fingern auseinander machen und dann zoomt das Bild mit. Sie haben darauf vertraut, dass durch den Hype und durch die Introduktionen und den Filmchen, die man nachgucken kann, dass Leute das so lernen und damit ist der Interface ganz clean. Zum Beispiel, das haben sie gemacht. Weiter kommt in den iPhone fast kein Options-Menü vor, was in normalen Telefonen überall ist und der Standard-Bedingung ist. Sie sind das alles umgegangen, haben den ganzen Touchscreen ideal benutzt, haben darauf aufgesetzt und haben sich nicht leiten lassen von der Status-Quo auf den Desktop oder bei Moda. Und das haben sie gut gemacht.
Also du vertrittst schon so die These, dass das iPhone auch die User-Interface-Revolution ist, die es von sich selbst behauptet.
Ich finde einfach, dass es sehr gut gelungen ist und dass sie in vielen von diesen Fallen nicht reingelaufen sind und sich grundlegend überlegt haben, was kann man, wenn es das ist, was kann man da eigentlich gut machen und sie hatte die Freiheit, um nicht anfangen zu müssen mit irgendwelchen existierenden Stück Software.
Gibt es auch irgendetwas, was sie nicht hinbekommen haben? Also gibt es irgendetwas, was dir nicht gefällt?
Lass mal so sagen, jeden, der dieses Ding benutzt, sagt irgendwie, ich vermisse das. Jede vermisst etwas an einem iPhone, aber wenn man das alles wieder reingemacht hat, war es wieder dreimal so groß geworden und nicht so elegant und nicht so to the point und nicht so einfach zu bedienen.
Also Copy und Paste zum Beispiel.
Genau, unter anderem jede Menge Bugs kann man auch finden, aber im Allgemeinen finde ich es sehr gut gelungen.
Hast du es auch schon mal in der Hand gehabt, Ellen?
Ich habe es auch schon mal in der Hand gehabt, ja.
Aber du bist nicht so begeistert.
Ich hatte es nicht so lange in der Hand und Mobile-Devices ist ja eher Peters Spezialgebiet auch.
Gut, aber so Telefon benutzen, du wirst ja auch schon mal die Anfrohung gehabt haben, oder?
Ich könnte das jetzt nur sehr persönlich bewerten und ich bin einfach nicht so ein Mobile-Freak.
Das muss doch gesagt werden. Was ich jetzt alles gesagt habe, ist alles aus der Sicht von der Architekt. Also wie macht man es gut für Millionen Leute? Wenn ich so ein Ding selbst besitzen würde, dann wäre ich nach einer Weile auch für verschiedene Sachen doch......nichts ausgefällt. Ich werde was vermissen, irgendwie wird mir das nicht gefallen, weil es musste halt für 900.000 andere Leute besser gemacht werden.
Das iPhone ist jetzt ganz neu und mobile ist vielleicht auch noch mal eine andere... also vielleicht auch die neue Herausforderung. Ich meine, Touchscreen, Multitouch ist natürlich dann auch noch mal ein komplett neues Interaktionsmodell. Das muss ich jetzt erstmal bewähren. Aber wie sieht es denn jetzt im klassischen Bereich aus? So der Desktop, der sich ja irgendwie zumindest in den Köpfen festgesetzt hat und der dann auch eigentlich real immer daherkommt. Ob man nun sich einen GNOME, KDE, einen Mac oder einen Windows vor die Nase wirft. Irgendwie hat man immer Fenster, man hat irgendwie Menüs, man hat so die Schar von Radio-Checkboxen und so weiter. Ist denn das alles jetzt so ausgereift, dass das unbedingt so sein muss? Oder ist das jetzt einfach nur so gekommen und keiner hat es verhindern können? Funktioniert das wirklich gut? Wird das noch lange tragen? Und welches dieser Systeme funktioniert denn jetzt eigentlich am besten? Jetzt würde ich mal deine Meinung dazu hören, Ellen. Nicht mal ein bisschen fest nageln, was dir eigentlich gefällt und was nicht.
Wir hatten ja vorhin schon mal über den Joy of Use gesprochen und der Mac spielt da natürlich sehr mit. Also tausend kleine Animationen, diese Light Traces.
Du weißt ja, so pulsierende rote, blaue Buttons.
Oder wenn man das Fenster schließt, geht das halt organisch und in den Dock und schlupst weg.
Aber dir macht das nicht wirklich Spaß?
Doch, ich finde das auch toll. Ich finde das auch wirklich sehr schön. Es ist halt nur immer aus Usability-Sicht darf eben dieser Joy of Use nicht die Usability stören. Also es kann halt immer nur ein Add-on zu einer sowieso schon guten Usability sein. Und dann ist das auch eine super Sache. Bei Mac gibt es einige sehr gute Beispiele. Also zum Beispiel, wenn man Word vermerkt, das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt ein Apple-Produkt, aber eben Microsoft Word für Apple und da diese Toolbox, die an der Seite offen ist, wenn man die schließt, dann verschwindet die ebenso, auch so dynamisch, organisch in so einem Blub in dem Toolbar-Button, mit dem man sie dann wieder öffnen kann. Also das heißt, man hat sogar noch einen Lerneffekt durch so ein Joy of Use Element. Also einerseits sieht es eben total schön aus, wenn es da reingeht und man weiß halt auch noch mit welchem Button kriege ich das dann wieder zurück. Das ist eine sehr schöne Sache, aber es gibt eben auch ein paar Beispiele.
So wie das Doc sozusagen dann auch.
Ja, genau. Oder wenn man abfällt C drückt für kopieren, also Steuerung C, auf Windows wäre es das, wird eben das Menü, das Hauptmenü kurz leuchtet kurz auf an der Stelle, wo sich der Menüeintrag befindet. Also Edit würde kurz aufleuchten. Das ist auch sehr gut und unterstützt auf jeden Fall die Usability, sogar noch zuträglich der Usability. Also nicht nur ein Etwan. Es gibt aber eben auch bei Mac recht viele Negativbeispiele, wo eben die Performance darunter leidet, was mich halt extrem stört, wenn man zum Beispiel...
Die Performance des Anwendens.
Ja, genau. Ich kann da nicht mehr so schnell damit arbeiten als Nutzer. Zum Beispiel. Es gibt ja diese Exposé-Funktion, wo man eben entweder über eine Funktionstaste oder indem man die Maus in der Ecke schleudert, eine Überlist über alle geöffneten Fenster bekommt. Die werden dann nebeneinander angeordnet. Mit der Maus kann man unheimlich schnell das richtige Fenster raussuchen und es nach vorne holen und dann eben da drin weiterarbeiten. Wenn man jetzt aber nicht mit der Maus arbeitet, sondern eben mit der Tastatur, dann muss man mit Tab durch diese Fenster durchgehen. Oder mit Pfeiltasten. Okay, wenn man das mit Tab macht, dann kommt jedes Fenster noch mal einzeln nach vorne. Das wird animiert. Das heißt, man kann nicht einfach durch die Übersicht zu durchtappen, sondern sie kommen nach vorne, was natürlich irgendwie auch wieder schön aussieht, aber eben extrem langsam ist und auch die Übersichtlichkeit wegnimmt, weil man eben nicht mehr alles auf einmal sieht, sondern die dann nacheinander eben so auftauchen.
Kann man mit Pfeiltasten machen?
Mit Pfeiltasten kommen die dann auch nicht nach vorne.
Nee, dann geht man so wirklich von Fenster zu Fenster. Da bin ich hier gerade selber so fest, jetzt wo du das sagst.
Aber ich würde es ja dann auch erstmal draufkommen.
Okay, das fand ich jetzt durchaus intuitiv, als du das erste was ausprobiert hast.
Oder ein anderes Beispiel ist halt auch dieses Quicksilver, so ein Schnell-Application-Lounger. Genau, richtig. Und der sieht auch irgendwie viel schicker aus als das Teil von KDE. Bei KDE gibt es auch so einen Launcher, da es einfach eine Eingabe fällt. Bei Mac, bei dem Quicksilver, das ist halt, man fängt an zu tippen und es erscheint wie ein Label. Also es sieht halt viel integrierter aus und viel besser. Das hatte Nachteile, dass man es nicht mehr editieren kann. Also man kann dann nicht rückwärts Taste und Text weiter, dann ist gleich das ganze Wort weg und wird halt von der Bedienung her, es ist einfach viel umständlicher. Und auch wieder ein Beispiel, wo halt der Joy of Use, also das schöne Aussehen, in den Vordergrund gestellt wurde und eben um frohe Funktionalität geht bei KDE. Fängt man halt an zu tippen, hat noch eine Text-Completion, also das heißt, er erkennt schon bei den ersten drei Buchstaben, was ich ungefähr möchte. Kann dann einfach einfach einbestellen.
Das ist eine spezielle Anwendung. Ich wollte schon nochmal mehr auf was sozusagen der Mac oder eben auch Windows, mir geht es jetzt nicht nur um den Mac, sondern es geht um alle Betriebssysteme. Und zwar deshalb, weil sie ja sozusagen alle mit diesem Anspruch herkommen, wir sind jetzt das User-Interface und wir wollen jetzt eine homogene Landschaft erstellen. Das ist ja eigentlich das Ziel, dass man möglichst homogene Benutzerexperiences hat, sodass ich eben das Wissen, was ich mit dem einen Programm angehäuft habe, möglichst weitgehend auch auf ein anderes übertragen kann. Welches dieser Systeme funktioniert da einfach besser? Wie auch immer du das bewerten möchtest.
Ja, also das Problem an Mac und auch an Windows ist eben, dass der größte Teil der Software nicht von Apple oder Microsoft selbst kommt, sondern eben von irgendwelchen Drittanbietern. Bei KDE oder GNOME ist das eben anders. Da wird der größte Teil der Software dann tatsächlich im Projekt entwickelt.
Aber auch von verschiedenen Dingen.
Schon von verschiedenen Leuten, aber trotzdem...
Da gibt es nur Drittentwickler eigentlich.
Aber trotzdem, also theoretisch wäre...
Ich bin ja ein passionierter Macintosh, damit jetzt hier nicht die Fahne schwingen. Gerade meine Erfahrung ist natürlich die, dass eben, egal, ob es nun ein Apple-Programm, also ein Programm, weiß ich nicht, von Apple noch dem Betriebssystem beigelegt wird oder von dem nochmal separat verkauft wird, wobei ich das auch noch nicht mal... Da gibt es auch durchaus Programme von Apple, die da überhaupt nicht mal einen Segen bekommen. Gerade die ganze professionelle Linie da, Final Cut Pro und so weiter, das sieht alles anders aus und andere Buttons und jeder Version nochmal neu. Aber gerade diese kleinen, netten Shareware-Programme und kleinsten 10-50 Dollar-Tools, die bedienen sich ja dann doch sehr reichhaltig in der umfangreichen Toolbox von Macintosh, also diese System-Frameworks, wo man ja mit sehr wenig Code schnell ein Programm zum Laufen kriegen kann und das erbt dann einfach extrem viel von der Standard-Funktionalität. Also was mich zum Beispiel immer wieder total verrückt macht, ist, wenn ich den Firefox starte auf meinem Macintosh und ich oben in dieser Adresszeile bin, um eine URL einzugeben, dann ist es einfach das einzige Programm auf meinem System, was sich die Frechheit herausnimmt, einfach das Editieren und das Navigieren des Cursors in dieser Zeile einfach anders zu machen als alle anderen. Da wird dann einfach nicht die Systemroutine benutzt, um dieses Ding zu editieren, sondern da haben sie sich irgendwas eigenes ausgedacht und ich mach irgendwie Cursor hoch und der Cursor ist halt nicht am Anfang der Zeit, wie er ist, einfach bei allen anderen Programmen den ganzen Tag über ist, nur da nicht. Dann muss ich jedes Mal so dann wie auf dem iPhone, dann laufe ich so gegen die Wand, es macht kurz so Bumm, du bist jetzt in einer anderen Welt und muss halt dann immer wieder umschalten und hab diesen kleinen Frustrationsmoment. Das ist so meine Erfahrung an der Stelle.
Na an sich hat Apple, auch weil sie da Mitte 80 Jahre der Pioniere war, vor das große Publikum rausbringen von einem GUI-System, Apple-Machintosh, 84 und weiter. In 86 haben sie mal die Guideline zusammengeschrieben, wie es dann eigentlich funktionieren soll. Und damit eine Tradition gesetzt, dass auf der ganzen Mechan-Tosh-Plattform immer besser organisiert war als jemals auf Windows.
Diese Mechan-Tosh User Interface Guidelines.
Genau, weil in zwei Jahren vorher kamen jede Programmierung erst zum Apple selber, wurde da geschult von irgendwelchen Programmieren.
Ist aber nicht so, dass sie sich selber daran gehalten hätten immer.
Was du sagst von den Pro-Applications von Apple selber. Einseits hat man da den Einfluss von, dass es wieder eine vertikale Industrie ist, also Specialist-Programmen. Zweitens sehe ich doch, dass da wirklich Innovation betrieben wird, die sie erst da entwickeln oder da ausprobieren und die später dann wieder einfließen, so langsam zickert in den Rest von dem System. Kann man so machen, kann man so managen eigentlich. Aber in Allgemeiner hat der ganze Mac-Plattform vor, dass da erstmal von dem User und den Firmen selber die Ansprüche viel höher sind. Man kann so sehen, wenn ein Windows-Programm nach Mac portiert wird, einfach von dem Windows-Programmierer, das stimmt überhaupt nicht. Das sieht man gleich von Fremdkörper. Da hat man einfach nicht das Gefühl, wie es so geht und was da der Feinschliff ist.
So wie dieser Firefox-Infekt eben, das ist eigentlich genauso.
Genau. Und ja, diese Ansprüche machen doch dann einen Unterschied, wie viel Zeit da reingesteckt wird, um es einfach kompakt, schön und geil zu machen am Ende.
Was ist denn mit Windows?
Ja, ich wollte erstmal noch etwas zu Linux oder den Vorteil meines Erachtens von Linux oder KDE gegenüber Mac und auch Windows. Also es ist nicht so modular. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel den Mac nehme und wieder ein Notificationsystem haben möchte oder einen Quick Launcher habe, muss ich das alles jeweils wieder extra installieren von einem Drittanbieter. Das ist nicht wirklich komplett integriert in das Betriebssystem. Also nicht Betriebssystem, aber in die Desktop-Environment. Bei KDE kommt halt wirklich alles aus einem Core. Bei GNOME ist das auch so. Also man spürt das einfach, dass es ein geschlossenes Ganzes ist. Das Notificationsystem und viele kleine Dinge, die man sich halt bei Mac oder Windows erst noch dazusuchen muss. Es ist vielleicht auch nicht so backfrei und nicht so poliert.
Das gebe ich auch zu. Mediendaten, Filme. Da bin ich voller Integration und gleiches User-Interface bei allen Programmen seit zehn Jahren gewohnt. Das sehe ich dann wiederum im Linusbereich überhaupt nicht. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie jetzt mit KDE 4.0 da was tut. Im Endeffekt gibt es ja dieses neue Multimedia-Framework. Wie hieß es noch gleich? Ich bin gespannt. Ich denke, da hat dann jeder seine eigene Gewichtung. Also was sozusagen jetzt wichtiger ist. So ein Launcher mag dann eben da wichtiger angesehen werden. Wird dann eben auf einer anderen Plattform erstmal durch eine dritte Partei beigesteuert.
Das kommt ganz klar auf den Enduser an. Also der Mac, darüber hatten wir uns auch beim letzten Stammtisch unterhalten. Er hat halt einfach auch eine andere Zielgruppe als ein KDE-Nutzer.
Ja, was ist denn die Zielgruppe? Ich meine, wir haben ja so schön darüber geredet, man muss die Zielgruppe kennen. Aber dann ist das doch eigentlich die erste Fragestellung gewesen, als man sich die genäht hat.
Ich hab mich mal am Linux-Tag zusammengesetzt mit verschiedenen KDE-Leuten, Soforstand und Sebastian...
Mit dem hab ich den Podcast mal gemacht.
Und da hab ich mal ein bisschen Consulting gemacht durch so ein Produkt-Show auf die Beine zu kriegen. Und da war es klar, dass es breiter wird. Und eigentlich war da auch die Zielsetzung, dass es doch die, lass ich mal sagen, die sophistigierte Hälfte von dem Markt, Leute, die doch eine Plattform möchten, wo der Feinschliff drüber gegangen ist, wo alles sehr geleckt aussieht, wo es auch sehr geschmeidig funktioniert usw. Dass das doch ein Ziel ist für die Zukunft.
Ja, aber halt auch immer noch hohe Anpassungsfähigkeit, also so Customizability, was ja auch jetzt schon klar eines der größten Probleme, aber auch eine der größten Stärken von KDE ist, dass man eben wirklich alles einstellen kann. Und das ist was, was die Community halt auch nicht verlieren möchte, wirklich hoch anpassungsfähig. Nur, dass diese Option anders integriert drin ist.
Das finde ich auch etwas, wo Unix, User Interfaces eine Chance haben, sich zu profilieren. Weil das ist glaube ich dann auch wirklich im starken Kontrast, insbesondere zum Macintosh, der einfach eine Customizability immer erst in dem Moment einführt, wo sich es nun überhaupt nicht mehr vermeiden lässt. Weil immer so dieser Ansatz da ist. Ich finde das auch kein schlechtes Prinzip. Bloß was hier vielleicht gelöst werden kann von KDE oder Gnome, ist diese Frage, gibt es einen Weg, Unlimited Customizability zu verbinden mit einem hervorragenden Default?
So macht der Max jetzt eigentlich. Die haben 20 Sachen, die man einstellen kann in der Preferences. Aber unter der Haube, via Default Writing, kann man zehnmal so viele Sachen steuern.
Aber dann muss ich auch gleich auf der Kommandozeile mich bewegen.
Das Mechanismus gibt es und man sieht jedes Mal wieder, da kommt irgendwelche Free-Verb-Applikationen, die es einfach in... Und das heißt, für 90% der Users, die es wirklich nicht interessiert, die sind 300, aber die drei sich nur interessieren, ist es genau richtig gemacht. Und für die anderen 10%, das sind genau die 10%, die sich auch sehr gut über das Internet solche Sachen in... Die meisten davon, das im Auge halten, und einen Tipp von, wie du Kontakte bekommst, von, oh, wenn du das Problem hast.
Was ist mit Windows? Taugt das irgendetwas? Also ich meine, das wird ja angeblich benutzt.
Und zwar, ja, da gibt es ein paar Probleme, oder da gibt es ein paar Sachen, die ich so strukturell sehe, bei Windows nicht so stark Guidelines vorgeschrieben, wie Sachen sein müssen. Es gibt unglaublich viele Programme, die sehr vertikal sind, also Spezialistenprogramme für sehr spezielle Industrie, wo im Allgemeinen kann man sagen, Usability einfach schlecht oder null ist, weil es halt einfach nur von Ingenieuren zusammengeschraubt wird. Und die Sache ist Microsoft, wenn man Microsoft die Windows macht, die Word macht, oder den ganzen Office macht, was das sehr prägt in den ganzen Windows. Ja, es ist eine unglaubliche Bürokratie, wo ich immer wieder lese, dass die letzten 10 Jahre oder länger, 15 Jahre, die Usability-Abteilungen aufgebaut haben mit 200 sehr, sehr guten Leuten, wovon ich total nicht ans Zweifeln wie gut ich bin, die alle Star-Consultants in unserem Welt, die zum Beispiel bei Macintosh richtungsgegebende Sachen entwickelt haben, so wie wir alle gewohnt sind, auf jeder Plattform zu arbeiten mit Window-Umgebungen, die haben dann auch Microsoft beraten. Und am Ende sehe ich nichts davon rauskommen. Bisher, jetzt soll es bei der neuen Vista, sicher bei der neuen Office, soll da mal wirklich was durchgezickt sein, was von Usability-Specialisten gemacht werden. Aber bisher war es so, die Abteilungen haben Research gemacht, die Consultants haben beraten und dann verschwand das in den Schubladen und die Ingenieure haben sich einfach gemacht, was sie wollten. Und das ist auch eine Frage von starke Organisation, die sagt, wir haben diese Prozesse, Usability gibt da den Ton an, Usability gibt Richtung, Interaktionslehrerdesign schreibt einfach vor, wie es wird. Und zweitens, ja, den Kontur von macht der Ingenieur, was er einfach für sich selbst gut findet, oder macht man als Team zusammen, Specialisten, Usability-Specialisten, Interaktionsspecialisten, mit dem Engineering zusammen, ein Produkt, das einfach für ein paar Hundert Millionen Leute gut funktioniert. Und das letzte soll dann so langsam kommen bei Microsoft, aber habe ich bis hier, bis XP, bis in der vorletzten Office-Version noch nicht bemerkt.
Das heißt, bei Windows tut sich nichts? Liegt das vielleicht daran, wie Tim Pritlove sagt, dass Bill Gates keinen Stil hat? Ich meine, er ist jetzt nicht getan, aber ich glaube, sein Nachfolger hat noch weniger Stil.
Es hat damit zu tun, dass Microsoft als ein Engineering-Bude angefangen ist mit fünf Leuten. Jetzt sind 70.000 Leute in der Campus. Und es ist immer noch ein engineersgetriebener, der jetzt ein Product-Manager dabei gekommen ist, aber kein von beiden. Er fühlt den Schmerz, wenn es schlecht ist oder hat ein Fingerspitzengefühl, um es besser zu machen. Und wenn die Prozesse nicht da sind, wenn der Chef nicht sagt, hey, jetzt geht nichts hier raus, bevor es wirklich die Usability prima testet und es einfach super eleganter anfühlt, Joy of Use. Wenn der Chef es nicht sagt, dann wird es einfach nicht gemacht, weil jeder hat Deadlines, jeder versucht, seine eigenen Planungsfehler zu verdecken und einfach ein Stück Software rauszuschieben.
Vielleicht müssen wir nochmal das andere große Betriebssystem auch noch erwähnen, was es ja auch noch gibt. Neben Windows und KDE und GNOME und Macintosh gibt es ja auch noch das World Wide Web, was sich ja nun in zunehmendem Maße auch als Applikationslieferant empfiehlt. Ich will jetzt nicht Web 2.0 gesagt haben, aber es ist vollkommen klar, dass in zunehmendem Maße Anwendungen auch über das Web zu einem finden. Das zeigt das iPhone natürlich auch wunderbar, dass derzeit die einzige mögliche, zumindest die einzige offizielle erlaubte Möglichkeit ist, dafür zu entwickeln. Das wird sich wahrscheinlich in ein paar Tagen schon geändert haben. Aber trotzdem sieht man ja auch, dass diese Anwendungen letztlich mit denselben Problemen kämpfen. Also Benutzer stehen davor und haben die Maus in der Hand und jetzt müssen sie irgendwas machen. Habt ihr euch mit Web-Anwendungen auch beschäftigt? Ja, das hattet ihr glaube ich auch schon erwähnt.
Nein, Angst macht das uns nicht.
Wie gut sind denn die Webseiten heutzutage?
Also sie werden schon zunehmend besser, was sich halt am Anfang in dieser ganzen Web 2.0-Blase gezeigt hat, dass die Entwickler ähnliche Fehler gemacht haben wie am Anfang im Anwendungsdesign. Also dass sie auf einmal wieder anfingen, auch sehr modular zu arbeiten, statt die Use-Cases zu unterstützen. Ja, technisch modular.
Den Interface zu organisieren, nach wie die Features sich organisieren lassen oder wie sich es technisch organisieren lässt. Obwohl, wenn man wirklich durch einen Workflow geht, sieht man, dass es sich alles vermischt. Und dass da alles zusammenkommt. Und dass es einfach eine andere Ansicht ist, eine dritte Dimension, die aus der Sicht von Marketing und Engineering nicht wahrgenommen wird.
Ich glaube, das war am Anfang vor allem ein Problem, weil das eine neue Technologie war und plötzlich Leute diese Technologie entwickelt haben, die vorher eben, also Ajax eben entwickelt haben, die vorher ganz andere Skript-Sprachen verwendet haben. Und dass sie da eben auch einen Lernprozess hatten. Inzwischen ist das ja auch wirklich sehr viel besser geworden.
Es hat sicher damit zu tun, dass vorher war die Trennung klarer. Das Web war seine eigene Plattform, das war seiteorientiert. Der Desktop war windoworientiert mit Dialogen oben drauf. Und viel fand statt auf dem Desktop in derselbe Window. Und auf der Webseite musste man von Seite zu Seite gehen ohne innerhalb Frames arbeiten, um Sachen gemacht zu kriegen. Und plötzlich mit Web 2.0 kann man sich viel langer auf der selben Seite aufhalten und dann klappen Sachen auf und wird die Daten geupdatet und kommen Knöpfe dabei, die gehen weg. Also jetzt hat man, und so vieles auch, wo es vorher klare Trennung gab, gibt es jetzt einen Hybrid. Und ja, da mussten alle damit zurechtkommen. Da musste ich als Architekt damit zurechtkommen. Aber wenn die Ingenieure sich selbst basteln, dann musste sie mit den Möglichkeiten, klar, offnen sich da ein ganzer Feld von Möglichkeiten.
Aber auch auf dem Desktop gibt es ja auch so eine Bewegung, dass man eigentlich wegkommt von vielen Fenstern hin zu Single-Window-Paint-Interfaces, das sehe ich in letzter Zeit in vielen Programmen und empfinde es auch selber als sehr angenehm. Also dass man sozusagen sehr viel mehr darauf achtet, dass immer alles in einem Fenster ist und dort auch sich möglichst wenig überlappt, was ja dann auch mit dem Web ganz gut passt.
Aber in dem Web 2.0 ist es auch klar, dass man gewisse Sachen wegen der Performance, wegen einfach wie das noch innerhalb eines Browsers tickt, dass man die nicht machen kann, so wie auf dem Desktop. Also wirklich einen vollen Menu-Bar da einzufügen, sehe ich einfach nicht vor mir. Man muss viel mehr da mit Flecken und Knöpfen arbeiten. Und genau diesen, wenn man erst in Web-Programmierung war oder auf dem Desktop programmiert, und man kommt in diese hybride Umgebung, wo für jede von diesen zwei Gruppen sich plötzlich eine totale neue Dimension öffnet, es viele Möglichkeiten gibt, es in die meisten, aber auch nicht alle, doch da, ok, da sind Grafiker-Profis dabei, so wirklich schief in den Grafikbereich kann es da nicht gehen, aber Grafik-Profis muss auch wissen, dass sie kein Interaktions-Profis sind. Und ja, sie kommen in einem Schwammgebiet, sie stehen so ganz schwach, weil in einer normalen Vertrautumgebung sind sie da nicht sicher, was sie da machen sollen. Also sehe ich, wie schwierig es ist, um das neue Gebiet auszuforschen, da an die Wand zu sitzen, man rennt dagegen. Und das ist inneren ein Problem oder ein neues Feld. Da muss ich jetzt alle zurechtfinden, was da der neue Modus wird. Und es wird nach der Statischen Web seine eigenen Medien wieder, wird da geschaffen.
Gibt es denn, ich glaube, ein gutes Beispiel, gibt es eine Web-Anwendung, wo er sagt, ah super, alles klar, hier ist irgendwie das mit der Interaktion, mit der Usability verstanden worden. Ich meine, als Experte, da ist man wahrscheinlich immer kritisch, aber vielleicht irgendwas, was nicht komplett unten runterfällt. Also ich habe zum Beispiel jetzt, ich bin ja ganz wertfrei, ich nannte natürlich nicht vollständig, aber was ich zum Beispiel extrem aufgeräumt empfand, ist Twitter zum Beispiel, was ja auch so ein komplett neues Kommunikationsmodell mit sich einbringt, was aber auch wirklich in der ganzen Web-Darstellung einfach einfach ist.
Leider keine Erfahrung.
Twitter habe ich auch noch nicht selbst ausprobiert.
Oder Google-Anwendungen, keine Ahnung. Ich meine, Google versucht ja auch wirklich da einen Spagat im Web, wirklich Anwendungen zu machen, die es dann wiederum schon mit Desktop-Anwendungen auch aufnehmen kann.
Okay, ich betreibe zum Beispiel den GIMP GIMP Visual Brainstorm-Webseite, das ist ein Blog, und die läuft bei einem Blogger. Und wo man seinen Beiträge reinschicken kann, ist eine Gmail-Adresse. Die beiden kombiniere ich dann, um da eine gewisse Brainstorm-Plattform da zu machen. Da ist einfach Manpower dazwischen, um das von dem einen nach dem anderen überzutanken. Aber das war das Einfachste und das läuft einfach so. Das sind beide so Web 2.0-mäßige Applikationen. Und in den Browsern, die ich benutze, läuft das einfach nicht einwandfrei. Da geht es ständig einfach so gut ab. Und an bestimmten Momenten kann man plötzlich durch die Kulisse durchgucken, weil plötzlich geht es technisch nicht so brillant. Und plötzlich, man hat so ein Experience und man war schon drin und alles, was er logisch plötzlich, stürzt es eigentlich auf den Experience-Level ab. Das hat mit langer Wartezeit, mit Feedback, die da nicht kommt, wenn ich meine FDP-Update mache von dem Ding oder so. Das sind so alles Usability-Sachen. Das bedeutet informieren, auf den Laufenden halten, guten Feedback geben und so weiter. Wie einfach nicht so gut gehen und davor sorgen, dass man eigentlich da einen Vertrauensbruch hat. Und das ist nicht schön für eine Plattform. Dass man denkt, ah, geht es wieder gut dieses Mal.
Ich wollte jetzt noch mal etwas finden, was einem vielleicht auch mal für den Zuhörer sagt, da kann man sich auch mal was abgucken. Da gibt es gute Entwicklungen, da ist alles prima. Aber der Kritiker ist nie zufrieden.
Nein, es gibt halt sehr gute Elemente. Oft ist die Zusammenstellung der Elemente dann nicht mehr ganz fabelhaft. Es gibt auch eine Zusammenstellung von solchen Design-Patterns, also von Elementen, die dann auf Web 2.0-Seiten verwendet werden. Da gibt es von Yahoo eine Design-Pattern-Galerie und dann gibt es uipatterns.com oder.org, wo auch Einzelelemente dargestellt werden. Die beschreiben immer ein bestimmtes Interaktionsproblem. Zum Beispiel, wenn eine Webseite eine große Menge an usererzeugtem Content hat, dann wächst der natürlich auch exponentiell. Und man muss sich da irgendwie wieder durchfinden. Eine Lösung sind halt Tech-Clouds. Und dann ist eben Tech-Cloud als ein Interaktionsmuster dort aufgeführt, die aber natürlich in der Art, wie sie dort dargestellt ist, sehr kritisch ist, da das eben nicht wirklich eine gute Lösung ist, um an solche Dinge ranzugehen. Eine viel bessere Lösung wäre da zum Beispiel das Flamenco-Projekt von Berkeley. Da kann ich ja auch nochmal später den Link hinterlegen. Aber auf jeden Fall gibt es eben solche Ansätze, wo gute Interface-Patterns oder gute Praxissen dann einfach gesammelt werden und der Öffentlichkeit wieder zur Verfügung gestellt werden, sodass man sich da was abgucken kann. Auch der Interaktionsverlauf dokumentiert wird eben nicht nur in Screenshots, sondern man auch weiß, wie verhält sich das ganze Element.
Ja, Ansatz ist, dass es ein guter Wort ist, weil es gibt zum Beispiel in Blogger, wo man seine Blogseite einrichten kann, durch einfach ein paar Kästchen herumzuschieben und Sachen einzufügen. Unglaublich gutes Prinzip im Vergleich mit CSS-Editor beim Hand. Damit kann man es für ein paar hundert Millionen Leute viel einfacher machen, um einen Blog einzurichten und ein bisschen zu kopsemeißen, was customisert wird, ein bisschen Joy of Use, wenn es nicht so schief geht mit der Farme. Aber die Ausführung stößt da einfach auf Browser-Bugs, Browser-Unterschiede, geht doch nicht so geschmeidig. Warum öffnen sich Fenster, um da eine Ausbreitung eigentlich zuzufügen, wenn sich man da einfach eine Seitenleiste vornehmen konnte? Also in der Ausführung geht es da noch schief. Und einerseits ist das technisch nicht zu umgehen, weil die Leute sich eigentlich anlegen mit einer Art von Plattformen, einer Art von Medium Web 2.0. Da gibt es gewisse Grenzen, da versuchen sie, auf eine Applikationsart und Weise da über hinaus zu kommen. Aber da gibt es einfach harte Betonwände, wo man dagegen rennt und wo man entweder Gas zurücknehmen muss, um zu sehen, wie ambitieus man ist, oder man muss es lösen, so wie es geht, nach der Art von Plattform.
Also ich sehe schon, es ist nicht so einfach, euch mal ein paar konkrete Tipps oder Vorbilder aus der Nase zu ziehen.
Was ich auch noch sagen wollte ist, einerseits gibt es einen Unterschied zwischen einer Auffassung als User und ich bin auch User von ganz viel Software, wo ich mich noch nie professionell auseinandergesetzt habe. Ich benutze Software einfach als User, da bin ich wie jeder User einfach ein Konsument von einem Software, da habe ich Sachen, die ich vermisse, da habe ich Sachen, die nicht so glatt laufen usw. Aber da bin ich eigentlich nicht in der Lage, um da einen Experten Aussagen zu machen, weil ich diese ganze Anforderungsanalyse usw. nicht durchgegangen bin und welche Fischungen sie da hatte von einem Software usw. Bin ich der richtige User oder missbrauche ich eigentlich den Software?
Bin ich die Zielgruppe?
Ja, weil viele Leute wollen zum Beispiel Gimp hijacken, um bestimmte Ziele damit zu errichten, weil es zufällig alles mit Pixels machen kann. Aber es ist einfach nicht davon gemacht. Und die Beschwerde, die sie haben, lassen sie sich einfach richten mit. Davor ist es eigentlich nicht gemacht und wir werden es auch nicht machen, weil sonst wird es nicht noch mal zweimal so groß.
Okay, ich denke wir sollten das jetzt mal alles hier zum Abschluss bringen. War ja ein sehr ausführlicher und interessanter Einblick in die Welt von Usability und Interaktionsdesign. Vielleicht zum Schluss noch mal kurz zu eurem Projekt Open Usability zurück. Wer soll zu euch kommen? Sponsoren hatten wir schon. Aber du hast ja gesagt, es ist eine Partnervermittlung einerseits von Entwicklern, andererseits von Usability-Experten oder welchen, die es werden sollen. Wie läuft das dann ab und was wünscht ihr euch sozusagen? Gibt es noch irgendetwas, was ihr einladen möchtet?
Wir wünschen uns noch mehr Usability-Experten oder Studenten der Usability, die mitarbeiten, die Lust haben, ein OMSource-Projekt zu betreuen.
Das geht auch so an einen Kommunikationsdesigner zum Beispiel.
Richtig, es gibt ja nicht wirklich diesen Studiengang Usability. Der ist ja ganz weit gefächert.
Vielleicht nehmen wir mal ein paar andere.
Wir haben Physik studiert, Kommunikationswissenschaften, Psychologen.
Es gibt fast nur Quereinsteiger, außer ein paar sehr gezielte Usability-Studiengänge, aber dafür gibt es auch wieder viel zu wenig. Aber im Meinfeld, im Interaktions-Architekten-Feld, da kann man von unglaublich vielen Studien eigentlich rankommen. Und aus meiner Sicht gibt es keine kompletten Studien, wo man auch mal praxisgerecht ausgebildet wird.
Vielleicht ist es ja auch was für Architekten. Also die haben ja so ein eigenes Problem, einen Job zu finden. Da wäre das ja vielleicht mal wieder ein Stieg.
Ich denke, man hat einen sehr guten im Problemlösen, in das Ganze sehen, einen sehr guten Hintergrund als normaler Bauarchitekt, wenn man sich dann wieder selbst eine Erfahrung dabeisammelt aus diesem Gebiet von wie ticken diese Architekturen auf den Desktop und so weiter. Das ist nicht schlecht, aber aus dem Designfeld, aus dem Psychologiefeld, selbst aus Mathematik und Physik, wo man sehr stark konzeptuell arbeiten muss, muss man sich zusammen mit diesen anderen Feldern das Wissen zusammen kratzen, um bei unserem Feld tätig zu werden. Und da bieten wir die Chance, sich vor Berufseinsteigern um sich Erfahrungen zu sammeln mit als Mentor ein erfahrener Profi.
Okay, wenn sich jetzt die Leute schon in das Wasser im Munde zusammenläuft, wo geht das hin?
Na, Studenten können bei der nächsten Season of Usability mitmachen. Also wir haben immer so eine Hauptsaison im Jahr, wo wir dann so acht bis zehn Projekte anbieten. Na, erst nächste Woche ist der Call for Projects und da müssen wir Projekte auswählen, die wir dann anbieten werden. Und die Studenten können sich ab wahrscheinlich März oder April bewerben. 2008 haben wir jetzt gerade. Der Link ist seasonopenusability.org, da stehen alle Informationen.
Sollen wir Open Printing nochmal in der Werbung werfen?
Bitte, das Werbefenster ist noch geöffnet.
Ok, am 10. Januar 2008 ist eigentlich geschlossen, in der Bewerbung mit mir zu arbeiten an dem Open Printing-Projekt.
Das ist jetzt vor zwei Tagen gewesen.
Das heißt, Druckdialog für alle Linux-Plattformen, alle Linux-Distributionen und alle Printer der Welt. Ganz viel Innovation ist da drin, um dann zehn, zwanzig Jahre alte Probleme mit Druckdialogen zu beheben. Da gibt es ganz viel Design- und Spezifikationenarbeit zu machen. Nun kann man das Fach zusammen bei mir lernen. Also da gibt es noch mal eine Woche Zeit, um sich noch mal nachzubewerben.
Das ist auch nicht mehr zu überlegen für Studenten. Also wir hatten jetzt eben schon, ich weiß nicht, welche Studiengänge, da darf vielleicht noch eine Frage kommen, aber Kommunikationsdesign. Das ist ja auch durchaus ein Feld, wo man sich ja dann auch mal profilieren kann. Gibt es dann irgendwelche Zettel in die Hand, die sie dann vielleicht auch im Rahmen des Studiums für sich nutzen könnten?
Das beste an der Open Source ist, dass alles, was wir machen, wird öffentlich gemacht, wird öffentlich dokumentiert. Und man kann alles zeigen, wo in das Proprietary für Kunden, wo wir beide arbeiten, es immer geheim ist. Und das macht es nicht einfach, um Usability Popularity zu machen, weil alles ist geheim. Es ist unglaublich schwer zu wissen.
Aber sozusagen für die eigene Reputation dann auch hilfreich.
Kann sie es aber auch an der Uni anerkennen lassen. Also wir hatten bei der letzten Season of Usability 2, ein Student hat seine Diplomarbeit in dem Rahmen geschrieben. Also hat das Projekt genommen und dann die Diplomarbeit drüber geschrieben. Einer hat sich den jungen Computer Interaction Kurs, da mussten sie eine Übung machen, dann hat er sich das Season of Usability Projekt anerkennen lassen. Und im Moment, also jetzt Ende Januar starten, auch noch mal lose mit der Season of Usability verbundene Übungen an der FHTW München, also an der Fachhochschule für Technik München, wo auch eben ein Open Usability Mentor mit seinen Studenten an KDE-Anwendungen evaluieren wird.
Und gibt es außerdem Treffen in Berlin, oder gibt es noch andere regionale Strukturen, die vielleicht gründen sich ja noch weitere Stammtische?
Es gibt mindestens einen Dutzendstammtisch in ganz Deutschland.
Von der UPA organisiert auch.
Lokale, also UPA war nochmal...
Dieser Berufsverband Usability.
Okay, sowas gibt es schon.
Ja, der ist aus den USA, stammt der eigentlich, und der hat dann Chapters in allen möglichen Ländern.
Vielen Dank fürs Kommen. War ein super Gespräch. Und ja, hat meine Erwartung über erfüllt. Ellen und Peter, vielen Dank fürs Kommen. Das war Chaosradio Express, die Ausgabe Nummer 64. Und ja, ich hoffe, wir werden irgendwann nochmal einen Realitätsabgleich machen. Wenn neue revolutionäre Geräte auf dem Markt sind oder andere bahnbrechende Entwicklungen stattgefunden haben, euch kann ich nur empfehlen, klickt euch mal durch openusability.org und vielleicht nehmt ihr auch an den ein oder anderen Veranstaltungen teil, deren es viele gibt. Und wenn ihr in dem Bereich arbeitet oder meint, dass das vielleicht was für euch sein könnte, gibt es genug Möglichkeiten, sich dort zu betätigen und das auch im Rahmen eines Studiums sich vielleicht anerkennen zu lassen. Das ist doch schon mal was, oder? Ansonsten kann man natürlich auch die Sache der freien Software nach vorne bringen. Dort ist die Usability-Tätigkeit auch wirklich gefragt. Zumindest ist sie nötig. Okay, vielen Dank, Ellen und Peter. Und ich sage tschüss und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.